Boarding start to broadcast Shazamm
you've gotten really good at this job.
A fucking goddamn wizard.
This shit.
Now son,
I know exactly how to do it.
I get that shit up and running.
A lady's John,
welcome to,
uh,
this has got to be like our twelfth real
podcast or something like that.
I can't believe I've kept it up this
long and it's all because you fuckers
because that's awesome.
Here we go.
It's all because of you people.
Positive energy that I get from you
guys.
And all the,
uh,
all the people that I run into on the
road,
let's say they loved the podcast,
keeps me doing it.
So we're going to keep doing it and it's
fun as fuck,
you know.
And uh,
it's on itunes now.
You can get it on itunes.
I think it's just Joe Rogan podcasts.
That would have been.
Yeah.
The one that has the most ones.
There's a couple other ones that,
uh,
other people have created,
but this is the real one.
There's lots of people have noticed that
they've taken straight up bits and put
it on your,
on itunes and put underneath the podcast
name and get on.
You know,
my attitude about the Internet is always
that the Internet,
you know,
you can't,
um,
can't put any energy into trying to take
your shit down because uh,
especially as a comedian,
it's inconvenient sometimes.
Like I go places and people have already
seen bits that aren't out on anything
yet and they've seen it because somebody
youtube did and then,
you know,
Stan hope has a whole bit about,
how people will put your shit on Youtube
and it's not done and the waistband hope
works.
And the way I work with both work real
similar in that we have an idea and it's
never like totally done.
You keep adding to it and tweaking it.
And then when you put it on a recording,
at least there,
it's kind of done,
you know.
But oftentimes like I'll put something
on a recording and then like a week
afterwards or two weeks or even a month
later,
I have a better tagline.
So before the,
before the things,
even on television,
I have like a new better way to do it,
you know,
but somebody wants said to me that you
got to look at standup comedy as like
every performance is just,
they,
they're just capturing a moment in time,
which is true once you've got some good
stuff out there,
but it's not true if you don't have
anything good out there.
So if you don't like until like shiny,
happy Jihad.
I was not happy with any of my stuff.
I would do it.
And I was like,
oh,
sorry.
Like when I did that,
2005,
uh,
the one that's just called Joe Rogan
live,
when is out of print with no,
the one that was from the Netflix shows
from Netflix that uh,
we didn't.
Phoenix when I was doing that,
I was doing the man show,
UFC comedy and fear factor at the same
time.
I was doing all of them at once and I
was frazzled and it was just like,
it wasn't my best performance.
Like I wasn't a.
like when I,
when I look at it,
I say,
I think that I'm like tents.
I'm not like enjoying myself.
So I think,
you know,
but that's that one I consider like
that's a moment in time like that at
least it was better than the stuff that
I had before.
You know,
my,
my
first CD,
I liked some of the bits but it's like
my delivery was kind of fucked up back
then.
But now I looked at it,
you know,
I looked at the stuff that's out now.
It's like,
you know,
every now and then someone can like
videotape something like before way
before it becomes anything,
you know,
like you'll video tape me just talking
shit onstage and then you know,
it'll become a bit somewhere down the
line.
But you know,
most times someone,
if I go to a show somewhere,
if they're a fan of download my shit,
they might've already seen the premise,
you know what I mean?
And it might not be as fun for them.
You know,
it's like,
so it's like you could look at that,
it,
it hurts you,
but I don't think it does.
I think having stuff out on the Internet
that people enjoy is always good.
That's the big problem though with
everything like now like tv shows,
other like Hulu and stuff like that.
But you have to find out how to.
They want to share it.
They want to do that,
that concept,
but they also need to make a profit from
it,
which is kind of interesting how they
have to go about doing it.
Yeah.
It's like I think we're,
we're experiencing a whole new model and
I think uh,
your attitude about how your fans get
your stuff is very important.
It's very important because it
represents how you feel like as a
performer and like what you feel the
relationship that you have with
audiences,
you know.
And if I was like this greedy dude that
was like,
you know,
fuck them,
they got to fucking pay.
You don't want my fucking money.
Like if you really,
if you really think like that,
like these people are just like you and
be fucking honest man.
If you were 18 years old and you a
broke,
you gotta fucking download Shit,
you're just going to do it.
It doesn't mean you're not a fan.
I mean sometimes you broke,
you know,
and I think is if you have people,
I think if you have a certain attitude
about like what you do and that attitude
is that you're just trying to create
things and you're trying to make money
off of it,
but really trying to create things that
people are going to enjoy.
Like that's the most important thing.
It's not that making money saying it's
the money will come if you work and if
people enjoy your work,
they're going to support you.
People are going to come to see your
shows,
they're going to buy dvds if they have
the money,
they have the money.
Like if I like there's a band that I
really liked out,
download their shit online like on
itunes and then I'll buy a CD to,
to play in my car just because I want to
support them.
Just got to really enjoy them.
I don't need.
I could hook my ipod up to my car,
but I will.
I will spend that money because I want
to support them.
Any movie that's good.
Even if I'm not gonna,
watch the DVD.
I buy it.
I always buy it.
If I enjoyed it in the movie theater,
I buy it and I feel like I'm supporting
artists when I do that and I feel like
that's what people got to do to that.
The Internet is a crazy new thing,
man,
you know,
and I think it's going to.
We're going to get to this weird point
where.
See Right now it's just information,
you know right now the ability to send
information.
It's pretty profound and like how,
how our world has changed,
but it's only information right now.
Eventually it's going to be more than
information when they come up with.
I was talking to cliff,
he be my friend cliff from EPA Games.
He's the coolest.
Cliffy B is the dude.
He's the main man behind gears of war,
the whole series of them,
the unreal games.
Super,
super cool dude.
Like a really fun guy.
And he came to my comedy show and then
um,
he came,
we came to the UFC afterwards and then
we even hung out.
He came to the after party and we were
talking,
he was a super cool guy and we were
talking about,
um,
the,
the ability eventually of making
printers that can print up things like
that's like really what's going to
happen eventually.
Kind of real.
Yeah.
Printers that can make,
they can make some,
he was talking about three d models that
they can make with these,
but they're going to get to a point and
it's not that far off where you say if
your mouse breaks,
you're going to be able to go to this
computer printer thing and you're going
to be able to put in the combinations.
So whatever the fuck you have to say to
get a mouse or download a mouse program
and a mouse is going to fucking appear
in your.
I mean,
you're really gonna be able to make
things with a printer,
you know.
And remember the first printers that
were old and clumsy and fucked up and
slow.
Then I have this new epson.
It's just like 100 bucks or something,
maybe a hundred 50 bucks.
The fucking thing is like lightning
pages just flying by.
You can print,
you can print it from the road.
You can call it up.
I mean,
it's insane.
There's programs that you can.
You can get on your God damn iphone.
We could print it up from your computer.
My old apartment just somebody had a
wireless printer and they just had an
open,
so I'd sit there and find the biggest
goat cifo get with herpes and I'll throw
it in,
print it on their printer,
stopped 50 pages and it never went away
and in fact printing successful.
That's also funny how much you that that
happened.
You could pretty much go through any
neighbor there and get on somebody's
printer and do that.
It's so fun.
Just take your laptop.
Gives me three plus hotspot.
That's obvious.
You could wreck some marriages like
that.
If you knew a dude who had a parental
like that,
you could send him.
Just doctored up photoshop pictures of
him blowing dudes or you could start
with photoshop him like marriages.
You know?
That's the golden rule.
That's the other golden rule about the
internet.
If there's a picture of you on the
Internet,
someone,
someone their photoshop to dick in your
mouth,
for sure.
Not many,
many dicks broken shore.
If there's a photo of you,
there's a dick in your mouth.
It's probably one year,
but there's sticks all around you.
There's so many dicks.
Have me pictures with Dick's online.
Just this one guy flap has done like a
thousand of them.
Right?
You know,
it's always me and just dicks
everywhere.
All over the place.
Totally.
Oh,
have you ever seen how a dildos are
made?
And uh,
like a asshole,
you know,
we could buy like a girls.
I haven't seen how they're made,
but I've seen them.
But you're fucking something that's
supposed to be a girl's body
dude.
They have people that sit there and
paint veins and veins,
like the Mexican ladies and they the
first day wiped his coat and they sit
there and have to stroke it for like an
hour and that does under vein.
So it looks like the skin underneath the
veins underneath the skin didn't have a
car,
they let that dry.
Then they have this person that just
does the purple ones,
but that's significant game veins.
Like the ones that have the main blood
flow to the tip of the Dick,
kind of smart.
It is the most creepiest thing that if
you look there and you feel like
somebody getting murdered and you're
watching it,
but it's just people making dildos.
It's.
And then when they cast her,
it's so true though.
It is like,
well what is it?
Why is it creep us out so much to see
like bodies,
like the idea of bodies.
I don't know because it's,
I don't know.
It's terrible.
It's like body parts and stuff.
It's terrifying to people.
And then when they make a cast,
like if they have fucking Ron,
Jeremy come in there and they're like,
all right,
we're going to do a chubby deal with
that.
This week they had to put his dick in
like this tube.
Almost like when you ever see like a
horse,
they're trying to get sperm from a horse
to make babies or something like that.
They have to like Jack it off into this
tube and they had the same thing with
uh,
how they have to sit there with this
plaster and he can't touch it.
He has to stay hard for five minutes.
He can't,
he has to have his girl or another,
like a porn star girl to sit there and
whisper like I want you to have a whole
oh your balls balls and do it for five
minutes.
You are the least sexy chick ever.
Do these sexy imitation of a chick and
history.
And I didn't care if I was in jail for a
year,
I wouldn't fuck you.
Like a burden.
But yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
And then with the cast they just have to
like put plaster in your fucking vagina
and just fucking sit there for five
minutes and they pull up this thing and
then they don't,
they don't just play paste hair on it.
They actually have to.
So with a thread and needle every single
hair on the pussy,
that's ridiculous.
Go to a dildo factory.
I think there's one in studio city.
You got to take a trip there with a
camera or something.
I think they would let you.
That they did for Hbo Sixty years ago.
Yeah,
but dates hbo.
I'm just a comedian.
I don't know if they would do it just
for a regular dude,
unless they were like UFC fans.
Dude the UFC.
But they think they would want to like
show people if you let them get with the
basic.
No,
he would never do that $100,000.
I'm not getting a boner in front of any
dude.
No,
no,
no.
People are doing all of the scientists
like shut the fuck up.
That would be weird though,
because that's what was after in this
video.
I saw that the porn star.
I did it just.
There was a box of his dick's.
He comes up and hilarious.
My Dick time.
$500.
What a great idea though because people
are such freaks.
They watched someone fucking a video and
they want to be like that person.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
I want to get one just to see what it's
like.
They have ones now.
Crazy,
Huh?
Yeah.
What,
what,
what kind of a human
being thought that up?
The first guy.
A really good warranty priest.
Let's just get someone and we'll make an
exact mold of their body so we can fuck
it.
Yeah.
How crazy is it?
This,
this new thing about the.
The priests.
You know what's happening that they're a
equating there.
Them being persecuted for kid fucking to
the Holocaust and the pope say going to
save them all.
That's what they're saying to south
park.
Let's talk about that.
What is going on?
Like how crazy is the Catholic religion?
The fact,
the fact that it's still around is mind
boggling,
but the fact that anybody takes him
seriously,
are all these fucking kids get molested?
Like how many kids have to get molested
before someone steps in and goes,
oh,
maybe these guys aren't directly tied to
God.
Like maybe,
maybe,
maybe.
Maybe we've been fooled.
Right?
I mean,
it's just amazing that a cult can have
so much power in 2010 and and that
nobody wants to call it a cult and
everybody wants to pretend that there's
something sacred about it because it's
been around forever.
Like it's the craziest,
most fucked up idea ever.
And there was a big discussion about it
on our message board and one of the most
interesting arguments was so people were
saying,
you're your discounting all the positive
work that the Catholic Church does,
but I'm saying anything positive that
they do,
well,
they do charities or that's,
that's them doing things outside of
religion that doesn't have anything to
do with the fucking religion.
That's just people doing charitable
things.
That does not make up for kid fucking.
That does not make up for living a life
filled with guilt so they can control
you and keeping you down like a little
bitch.
Terrified about every fucking thing you
do because you're going to burn in hell.
And anybody who's ever been a Catholic
school knows that.
Yeah.
I did a year in Catholic school,
man,
and it was like I did a year in jail.
My first grade,
first grade I went to Catholic school,
Our Lady of chest,
Jehovah,
and uh,
in,
in New Jersey and this fucking cunt nun,
sister Mary Josephine.
I was like a pretty happy kid before
this happened,
you know,
my parents had just broken up and the
impact of it hadn't hit me yet,
you know,
but I was still in denial,
but I would see my dad's still because
we were still in New Jersey.
And then while this was going on,
I went to Catholic school for a year and
it was horrifying.
It was brutal.
Dude.
This nun was such a fucking cunt.
Everything,
everything you did,
she would just be on you.
She will tell you she's going to make
you sit on a nail and the closet,
she's going to have to stay overnight.
And she was just as haggard old bitch
that nobody loved.
Nobody had fun with her.
Nobody told jokes to her.
She never danced.
She never supposedly never fucked,
you know,
she wasn't allowed to do shit.
She was just the worst representation of
an elderly woman.
Possible.
The best would be a woman who's lived a
life of joy and she's just super
friendly to everybody because she feels
so blessed
that she made it through this.
This is great.
This fucking con.
She used to hit us.
She really used to hit us like people
think like Catholic school teachers
don't hit you with rulers.
No,
they fucking hit you with rulers,
but that's real shit.
They'll smack you in the head.
It was brutal.
I was.
Every day was terrifying,
but I got awesome grades.
It was that crazy.
Like right after that.
I fell off school hardcore often that my
was in gifted classes and everything.
The next year after a Catholic school
and then I totally stopped trying and I
was sleeping.
I just.
I stayed up all night and just when
you're in a Catholic school,
you're so terrified.
You will push the everything.
You don't want to have a fucking see.
You don't have a big.
They'll yell at you.
They're monsters,
man.
You know?
I mean,
it's just that whole idea as a
philosophy is the worst idea possible.
That means you're putting the control of
your consciousness.
You're putting your trust in the wisdom
of someone who lives in a cult of kid
fuckers.
Really?
I mean,
look at that.
So that's what's going on.
A bunch of guys aren't allowed to fuck
women.
Oh,
that's real natural.
What,
what?
You're not allowed to have sex do.
You don't even.
They don't even get a better place in
heaven when they go to heaven.
They just get regular heaven just like
you.
If you listen to them,
it's ridiculous.
It's the dumbest fucking idea ever.
The dumbest idea ever.
And we have to pretend unlike CNN and
Shit,
that this is like a real issue of
debate,
you know,
and they'll,
there's abuse in the Catholic church,
but it's never like,
why the fuck do we still have the
Catholic Church?
It's never.
Nobody ever steps in and goes a really,
really all this,
these fucking guys in their robes and
they fuck kids and they live in these
crazy places together.
All men really.
And the,
the nuns are all evil.
And they all look haggard and beaten
Dab.
Oh,
a few of them do some charity work.
They do some good things to.
They donate some of the millions of
dollars.
They trick people into giving them.
They'd donate some of that and they do
some good things.
But yet you never really hear about this
shit.
And like the amish religion.
Catholicism is one of the worst ever.
The Catholics were controlling the
world.
We'd be fucked.
You mean everybody wants to fight off
the Muslims.
At least the Muslims like the other
Muslims,
Muslims like each other.
Catholics don't even like each other
though.
They're fucking controlling you with
death,
you know,
that's a crazy religion.
I guess Muslims if you believe in like,
you know,
the hardcore jihadists,
I guess they do to,
you know,
it's pretty similar.
You know,
cat Catholicism,
the only thing that has over over the,
the Muslims says you don't hear about
Catholics who said bars as much.
It's more rare.
Sure.
It's happened though,
right?
It's been Catholic suicide bombers.
Right.
You never see a Buddhist cock sucker.
You know,
you never Buddhist.
Yeah.
You're never going to be scared to be in
a tent in the middle of the woods with a
Buddhist guy.
You're not going to think he's going to
fucking rape you.
You're going to guys to protect me.
Instead.
A real Buddhist though,
people will argue that a real Catholic
wouldn't fuck kids too.
Yeah.
No,
and I think maybe that's just a former
retards and like to be around each other
happened.
I don't know what you know,
and people say,
Hey,
you guys talk about the subject of
religion a lot.
Like it comes up a lot,
shouldn't it?
Yeah.
What's all about?
What the fuck?
It's programming and then that's really
all it is.
No one knows anymore about what life is
all about and you do.
I mean,
we have wisdom,
we've learned things.
You know,
all of us have had different life
experiences that we've benefited from.
We try to express these to each other
and we can all get a little smarter in
the process,
but the reality is nobody really knows
what the fuck is going on and nobody
knows where this is going.
Nobody has any idea what this is,
you know this itself,
if this,
if we live this life,
this life would be the craziest drug
trip ever.
Okay.
If you had some sort of a logical two
dimensional life,
like a binary life,
like something you could read out on a
piece of paper.
If that was life and that life was
introduced to this life right here,
you would go,
this life is psychedelic,
this is insanity.
So everything is insane and it gets more
ridiculous by the minute,
you know,
I mean,
there'll be fucking CNN headline news
and they'll have a,
a,
an,
you know,
an episode on him is Kim Kardashians
asked too fat.
I mean,
they literally will do that.
you know,
this is where we're at this tiger woods
shit and this Jesse James Shit and all
this crazy stuff where we're
concentrating on,
on nonsense,
you know,
I mean,
we're so much more concerned with
dancing with the stars than we are,
but the fact that we're in the middle of
two fucking years
wars grazing,
we have too much info about Demi Moore.
We have too much info about these
current Dashi and people that would
normally not know about unless you rode
a horse in the town and somebody told
us.
It's so fascinating that it's so
fascinating,
isn't it?
I mean,
we are the weirdest animal ever.
If you didn't,
if people didn't exist and you made them
up,
it would be too much.
There you go.
This is ridiculous.
They can't be that fucked up like fucked
up and they figured out nuclear weapons
that fucked up and they can fly through
the air to all parts of the planet
there.
That fucked up.
God Damn.
They're really having a conversation
with the pope.
He's a fucking cult leader.
Like,
why are you sitting down with them?
This is ridiculous.
And they're like,
yeah,
well,
you have to play along with them.
No,
you don't have to play along with them
because playing along with them is a
concession that what they're saying is
legitimate.
They really represent something
meaningful.
It's nonsense.
The individuals inside that
organization,
they represent something meaningful.
They're individuals.
They're just trapped in this web of
ideology.
They're trapped in this thing.
They know I'm a Catholic,
I was born Catholic and the Catholic
like,
you're a fucking human.
Why are you lumping yourself in
voluntarily with this gigantic group of
people who believe nonsense?
That doesn't make any sense and no one's
saying that.
Anybody else has the answers like I'm
not saying I'm right and you're wrong,
or I know I have some information you
don't have.
I don't know anything or you know,
I have my own life that I can tell you
honestly what I've learned from my
experiences and things that I've read
that other people have researched,
but what do I really know about what the
fuck this is and what's next?
Nothing and I know as much as anybody
and you know as much as anybody.
There's not a single person who has more
of an more of a realistic view of the
next phase of existence.
Whether it exists at all.
No one knows and it doesn't help.
Pretending you do know.
That's what fucks everybody up with,
fucks everybody up is someone that
pretends they do know because then we
with our fucking monkey instincts,
just follow that guy and I'm like,
well,
he knows.
He knows.
He's so confident and this guy,
of course he's confident.
All these people are listening to them.
First of all,
he's crazy and then all these people are
listening to them and so the more people
listen to him,
the more he believes his own bullshit
and the more he really thinks he is
special and ordained and there to give
the word of the Lord and the more but
delusional they become.
I mean it's a,
it's a fucking classic Jim Jones
pattern,
you know?
I mean that's what it is,
is it's the,
the idea is completely ridiculous that
some guys who don't get pussy have the
answers.
Nobody has got the fucking answers and
there should be no ideologies like this.
This should be no predetermined patterns
of behavior that are attractive to
follow because anything predetermined
like that is gonna fuck you up because
it's not going to give you a realistic
map of the world.
You live in your map of the world.
Back when people had very little
information,
when Catholicism was created,
the map of the world was,
there was no internet.
There is no,
you know,
in an exchange of ideas,
there's no pornography available and
you're fucking iphone anywhere you look.
I mean there's so many things that are
different about that world than about
this world and so all their crazy
nonsense,
you know,
could be easily disproved if somebody
tried to start up that religion today,
you know,
it's just,
but it's there and it's been there
forever so people just fucking stick
with it.
It's the weirdest thing ever.
Like logically,
religion is one of the weirdest things
ever.
It's so hard to believe it's still
around.
You really got stopped watching.
Lost at the wrong time.
It wouldn't fucking getting really
intrical religion.
Yeah.
Well maybe I'll tune in.
I still got a minute.
I'm confused now.
You probably know religion a lot more
than me.
I really like do and I don't,
I don't.
I know,
I know Sir enough to get annoyed and
then when I started researching it more
becomes more and more cookie and then
then I can't take it anymore.
So I only know surface details of like
all religions,
but all I know about all of them as
they're all ideologies,
you know,
any,
anything like that as dangerous.
Anything where you've got older people,
when you grow up with these older people
that are telling you what,
what,
what's what you should and shouldn't do.
They don't know.
You know,
at best you know,
we exist really well in small tribes,
but I think
when,
when people are in small tribes,
those small tribes are so important to
stay alive.
These people have this intense bond of
family and I think what happened with
human beings is we went from small
tribes to gigantic countries so fast,
you know,
over the course of just a few thousand
years.
And I don't think our,
our body caught up with that.
I don't think our body has separated
itself from the fact that,
you know,
we really are all connected,
I think in the small tribes when they
were looking out for each other all the
time,
it was really like having a giant
family,
but we don't feel connected as a
country.
You know,
I don't,
I don't feel connected with all the
Americans,
you know?
That seems ridiculous.
There's 300 million of us.
So like how,
how can anybody connect to everybody
back then they could.
And that's how we're wired.
We're wired for that kind of life.
I think that's why so many people are
depressed.
I think people were depressed because
the energy in their life is imbalanced
because they don't have enough love and
compassion.
It's all about their life.
It's all about.
It's all about you need to just feel
love.
You don't need negative things.
It's like if you were on a plane and you
hear like a screaming kid right next to
and you're trying to sleep,
you know now might be different from you
because you know,
you have kids now,
but in the old days it used to just
drive.
You want to just fucking knocked the kid
out or something crazy.
It doesn't draw me.
It doesn't bother me at all anymore.
It's like,
it was like comforting.
Yeah,
I like it.
I liked kids.
What if I started crying?
What would have slapped you in the
waterfalls?
On your ass?
I went waterfalls on you the other day.
Brian gets bottled up.
It's funny.
I do once the once a year.
No,
I can give.
I can cry in movies and Shit,
man.
I cried in that Jeff bridges movie.
Crazy heart.
Oh really?
Oh,
I don't want to see that then.
I don't want to say I grew up a
motherfucker
got me a couple times.
They've gotten a couple times.
There was a spa one,
especially because it was about a little
kid,
a little kid getting lost.
I don't want to tell you anymore.
No,
I won't say anything.
Anybody.
I don't want to give away anything about
the movie,
but if you haven't seen it so bad ass,
I'll run it on my ipad tomorrow.
Did I use it?
No.
One is more of a technology junkie then
this motherfucker.
And if you have ever seen his youtube
page,
it's let's find Jesus,
right?
Uh,
let's.
Yeah,
Youtube backslash.
Let's find Jesus,
but it's got a red band back on.
Yeah,
I got a red band.
Dark Red Roll up there.
Again,
if you're ever thinking about getting
any kind of a camera or anything,
check out his reviews because he's like
the most thorough.
He's the biggest tech head I know and I
don't know anybody who is more of a
junkie of technology and more also more
knowledgeable like you're always on the
ball.
So many people giving shit on this ipad
and you are a little bit of an apple
fan.
I am an apple fanboy.
Know why?
That's why they're giving you shit.
You're excited.
They're really hating that you're
excited.
You know,
it's when you see what gets tricky,
not when you praise and object,
but when you start shitting on like the
kindle kid was dead,
fucking cute and then people's defend
their kindle and they get crazy.
You know,
now I'm not an apple fan.
Boy,
bullshit.
So many cameras.
I love so many cameras.
I liked the company.
I like to support something that I
believe in.
I think they're the best.
I love their little portable cameras
with the IPAD,
but what's crazy is before I was kind of
like tricking myself,
like,
yeah,
I just want to get netbook this is
better than a netbook.
I'm ready to support this thing.
But then lately they've been showing all
these applications and I'm like,
like they have netflix now,
so I'm going to teether Internet from my
cell phone and be able to watch netflix
anywhere I want to throughout the united
slugging them,
Hey,
this was losing his marbles.
I'm not.
I'm tired of people.
I'm just going to live.
I'm living in my fucking technology
road.
It's fucking great.
It's so funny because if you were forced
to live your life in front of a computer
and then someone allowed you to go
outside,
you'd be so happy to go outside.
Right.
You know,
it's because we're forced to live in
reality that the computer life seems so
much more interesting.
It seems more like it like I'm supposed
to.
I'm looking for something we always
talked about and that's why Google is
one of my favorite websites because I'm
searching for something always 30
percent of them do and that's the best
thing about my message board when I go
to that message board everyday I'm
looking,
what do you got?
What's going on?
What's happening?
What am I looking for?
I don't know.
I will click links and so literally
sometimes I'm nodding out to fucking
keyboard.
You ever do that?
Yeah.
I'm like nodding out keyboard.
You sitting there.
Usually I,
I'm,
I'm supposed to be writing and I just
start surfing the Internet and then next
thing you know I'm,
I'm not now and then I'm like,
what am I dealing with?
Kind of retarded mind.
I don't even know what I'm looking for.
I just keep checking,
I'll be ready to go to bed and then I'll
just say let me get online real quick
and see what's going on in the world
and you go to the same websites over and
over waiting for that one
almost or something like,
you know what man,
it's pretty bad ass as a comedian
though,
there's never been a better time to be
able to promote your gigs so much better
than it's ever been before because you
know you can,
you can get information out there and
you know,
you can,
you develop like a whole network of your
fans,
you know,
and on your twitter page and your
message board and people get to know
you,
like the real you.
It's not like the old days you would do
like an interview,
you know,
like somebody like Dean Martin or
something like that,
you know,
was a kid with a bell going.
Yeah,
I mean how do you get someone to show us
what they know about you is like you
would do like the Ed Sullivan show.
I know you go on stage and do like seven
minutes.
That's all you got mad right now.
You could,
you know,
I was telling Ari like we were,
were already,
who was a very funny guy as sometimes
has a hard time getting gigs on the road
and I was saying you should put together
something,
you know,
where you,
you do your best bits that you've ever
done and do and throw them up on youtube
because he has a lot of bits it doesn't
even do anymore because he's got new
bits and it might be you don't have
those old bits like in a video you
should make.
Make a video of your shit man,
you know,
and put that on Youtube.
I go,
you've got really good bits,
you know,
looked at the gay bar bed and like
there's a bunch of bits of the ads that
are really classic fits it doesn't do
anymore.
And I'm like,
take those put,
just throw them up on youtube man.
And then people see it,
they'll come see you at shows.
It's really the best method.
It's like,
you know,
the old method of like you would do like
a comedy central show.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I guess like some those stand up sit
downs or you know what a premium blend
or something like that.
There's like seven people in each.
You know,
there's like A.
I don't know how many is each shows that
an hour,
half an hour.
What is it?
How many comics go up and a premium?
Yeah,
our.
I think it's like for comics or
something like that,
people don't really.
They remember,
Oh,
there was that guy.
He was kind of funny,
but if they could just go to fucking
youtube anytime they want.
Like,
oh,
I thought this was funny,
I'm going to send it to your friend.
Do Listen,
this guy's hilarious.
And then he says it is right.
If that's what happens,
it just gets going.
Itunes is insane to me.
The other day I was trying to tell my
friend that his song.
I'm like,
no,
you got to hear the song.
Damn.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I have an iphone.
Downloaded it right into in a minute.
I purchased it,
download it,
and with a Bluetooth it to my stereo and
my car.
That's fucking.
I was like,
this is like a jukebox.
I have the best shoe box ever.
It's nuts that just that idea is crazy
and that shit's going to be in your car
and it's going to be voice activated.
You gonna be able to press a button and
say,
go to itunes and download rollingstones
tattoo you.
Bam.
That shit's gonna.
Have you seen the demos of the new
photoshop cs five or six or whatever it
is,
the new feature in it.
I'll do it.
It's on your message board.
Look under like new photoshops and on
the main form,
but I.
it's smart fixing.
So can you take a picture?
There's a treater is a shadow.
There's a glare.
There's somebody in the way of you.
You just circle it and cut it and what
it does,
it looks around it and tries to make its
own scene.
So you're just sitting there like trig
on Blair gone shadow gone.
It just like you have a brand,
like it does all the hard work that took
like hours and hours.
There's going to be the fake his photos,
you know,
photos are going to be real anymore.
Like pretty soon every photo you take,
like you can zoom into your face,
just a rate cut at wrinkle and I'll
take,
make her skin grow back.
Like we'll find out what your skin
textures.
You just see the video demo.
It's so crazy.
So yeah,
for those completely gone nap,
we're going to go to the moon
10 times next year.
It really is getting very strange.
Technology is getting very strange.
It's,
it really is.
Getting to have this weird point,
and we've talked about this before and
I've been talking about onstage lately.
There used to be that people,
and I wrote about this in my blog,
that when when they invented something,
it was to make their life better.
You know,
you the,
the first cavemen invented putting a
sharp stick,
you know,
poor appointed rock at the end of the
stick.
So like it's kill Santa and then they
invented a pot so they could take the
meat and put it inside and carry it
easier.
And then they invented all these.
It made their life easier.
What the fuck does the large Hadron do
to make your life easier?
Tag It looks awesome.
It looks.
It looks like the biggest robot
rollercoaster ever.
They need to make a movie in there too.
Two in there.
Can you imagine that?
Just to think of the idea behind it.
We are going to send Adams around a 27
kilometer circle,
a giant machine and to build up speed.
Did they get to like just below the
speed of light and they slam into each
other.
What the fuck?
That's awesome.
How is that trickling down to anybody?
I mean is there anything at a particle
physics that trickles down to to make
life more convenient for people at
anything?
I mean you're talking about like the
biggest scientific project in history.
There's 10,000
different scientists from 100 countries
and it's cost billions and billions of
dollars and I'm not criticizing it.
Don't get me wrong because somebody said
something about this like,
how could you attack science?
You know,
they're trying,
they're doing what they're trying.
I'm so not criticizing.
I am.
Oh,
I am not.
I'm not on one side of the other and I
don't.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with them doing this.
I'm just completely fascinated by it.
I am so fascinated by the idea that
they're trying to recreate the
conditions right after the big bang and
that's what they're looking for and
that's why they're doing this.
And probably something weird that it
would trickle down to like storage and
power,
like battery life is ridiculous like
that.
We're figuring out how to save power and
energy.
I mean maybe because they are making a
corrosion.
Yeah.
So it might be something weird like that
or it could be something game,
you know,
it could,
it could trickle down.
I guess.
I mean know who they'll be known for is
to say not that smart.
I mean when,
when things get really wonky is when
they really figured out how to crack
time when they figured out how to travel
through time,
you know,
and there's been like,
there's a model to this,
uh,
this fucking this scientist,
I think his name was Kurt or Dale was
like,
what else goes with the double?
Oh,
what is that called?
UHM,
lot.
Anyway,
he was this guy who figured out that if
you could,
you'd have to take a cylinder half the
size of the solar system and spinning at
the speed of light.
You have to cross it out.
I don't,
I don't remember exactly what the fuck,
you know,
the,
the formula was for it.
But if you did that,
if you actually created this thing that
was half the size of the solar system
moving at the speed of light somehow or
another,
you actually could your lack of time
like it is possible.
Like what the fuck?
What if,
what if they figure out something along
those lines.
Because the thing about people is we're
not gonna be satisfied with just the
large Hadron collider.
It's not like they're going to figure
this out.
They're going to create the Higgs Boson
particle and they go,
wow,
here we got it.
You know,
we did create the God particle and we,
we know that it's real.
What we know they're going to come.
There's going to be another thing is
going to be the going to try to get
crazier.
We think we can make a black hole.
Well if you think you'll make a black
hole,
let's not do it.
Well we don't know if we can make a
black hole,
but we think we can make and we think
it'll go away really quickly.
Like what?
That's their fucking with everything.
No one.
You know,
I thought I like a lot that we talked
about recently.
I always keep on going back to your
thinking is like how,
what if all this creek,
because lately I haven't had a lot of
crazy stuff go on in my life and I was
like,
what if me and you in the future like
iphone 50 or changing the past,
you know like,
Hey,
what do you want this month?
You want to,
you know what I mean?
Like we're creating our own past using
technology,
like changing time.
Remember when we were talking about like
how weird would that be?
Like if we could sit there now and go,
okay,
we can go back to 1989.
Oh you're,
you're eating pizza here.
Do you want something crazy to happen?
Were you eating pizza here?
Yeah.
Let's just throw in this crazy world,
right?
Because like lately it just seems like
all right,
this is like a.
because a lot of stuff that's happened
to me,
it seems like it's so insane that that
doesn't even seem real.
Like I'm waiting for a reality show.
Cameras to come out.
Yeah.
I don't know man,
you know,
I,
I've often thought that there's a path
that you're supposed to live in life and
then path will sort of illuminated
itself to you as you go along the way,
as long as you pay attention to your
instincts,
you know,
and uh,
I think a big part of that path,
it's like your attitude in life and how
you,
how you view things and how,
how you,
how you feel about yourself,
how you feel about life.
Right?
And I think in,
in as much as you can kind of dictate a
lot of that,
you can kind of decide how you view the
world.
You can kind of decide your,
your approach to things and you can
decide based on your instincts.
And I think if you do that,
then everything kind of just works out
as great way.
It's weird,
you know,
as long as you're doing the right
things,
it's like you have to really be a
positive person.
You have to really be disciplined so you
don't feel like you're slacking off on
all of the things that you should be
working on.
And there's like,
there's a certain balance,
there's a certain guiltiness that you
feel when you don't work hard enough at
something that's there for a reason,
right.
It's not necessarily you can get that
out of your life just by doing what
you're supposed to do and it feels
better.
You don't feel like you're self
defeating and the process,
you know,
I think,
I think there's,
there's a path to life,
dude.
And I think if you might think of very
being controlled by us in the future
using technology.
So that was our theory,
right?
Right.
I think maybe that is a possibility.
I mean,
who the fuck knows?
But I think what's more likely is that
every person sort of as ridiculous as
this sounds,
that every person's sort of fits into a,
a peace in this world and that this
world,
everything about it from bottled water
to fucking space shuttles,
that it's all connected.
And then it really is.
Even though it seems like life,
like we think of it as just life,
that's what we've labeled it.
Oh,
here's life on the world.
Here's all these people going about
their day,
here's,
you know,
a boat on the water.
We think about it like that.
But really all these things in this
life,
everything,
they all have a value.
They all have a position,
they all have a purpose.
And it really is like what we're living
in is we're living a gigantic
mathematical equation.
And I think that that's what all human
life,
animal life,
when wind and fucking earthquakes and
everything,
I think it's all a part of this insane
mathematical equation and that chaos in
life.
And you know,
earthquakes and meteor impacts,
these are all built into this equation.
This is how the system works.
It seems like this crazy randomness,
this fury of nature and you know,
and birth and death and you know,
and sexuality and creativity and you
know,
why was my childhood so bad?
And you know,
why was I raised in a wealthy family now
on lazy,
you know,
all these different,
these different things.
They all play like a little park and
this giant fucking equation.
It's just so big we can't see it and so
crazy and alien because it is us because
it is the world we live in.
It's almost impossible for us to really
see the big picture.
You know?
I think that's very possible,
very possibly what we're doing in this
world.
I think all of us are living a giant
mathematical equation and I think it
probably has something to do with
technology.
I mean,
no one treats that like,
like it's a serious possibility because
it's the subject of terminator movies,
you know,
but if you looked at what's going on,
you would see that technology is
increasing at a much faster rate of
evolution and human beings and if
essentially what we're capable of doing
as a human being is made calculations
and move and make decisions and you
know,
and have moral code and a judgment in
your mind.
I mean you could fucking program or
religion into a computer and it would
actually follow it.
You know,
you could give a computer a personality,
you could force a computer to react a
certain way,
the different things.
Then you figure out a way.
It's a put a computer so small that you
put it in an artificial body that you've
created with your fucking computer.
And the next thing you know,
you have computers making life and that
life is a computer and that computer is
living,
you know,
it's own version of this mathematical
program.
That's just as possible as us being a
part of a mathematical program.
Right?
You know,
it's,
it's all very possible that,
you know,
we are here to create technology and
then our,
our whole society is geared towards
creating technology.
The fact that like in China,
do you know how fucked up the pollution
isn't?
China?
It's insane.
They had this one city,
I forget what it is.
I think VBS TV did a,
uh,
a documentary on it.
This is one city where it's so bad there
that just breathing the air is like
smoking three packs of cigarettes a day.
It's pretty bad here too,
Joe.
The other day I was coming or driving to
my house and you can even see burbank
because happened to small.
Yeah.
That is bad.
And we just breathe it in every day.
It's not bad where you live,
but it's like
camp good for you.
It's
clean air.
That's one of the reasons.
Yeah.
Well I wanted to move to Colorado,
you know,
I wanted to get away from this
overpopulation
Austin,
Texas.
Well,
everybody says that though,
but that's why everybody's moving to
Austin.
You know,
I certainly think that places that are,
uh,
have less people are nicer.
We were in Charlotte,
North Carolina this week for the UFC and
uh,
people in Charlotte are so fucking nice.
That's my second place.
I would move South Carolina or North
Carolina,
Charlotte,
North Carolina.
And the people were so fucking cool.
Everybody was friendly.
Everybody was normal,
you know,
it was like,
it was a really nice place.
People were really nice though.
Everybody in restaurants and bars,
it's like there's less people.
People are more down home.
They're more friendly,
you know.
It was a good time.
Yeah.
This ain't the best way to live.
New York is where we were just at and
there was,
there was more interesting thing because
we went from New York to Charlotte,
North Carolina and Charlotte.
North Carolina is way better.
I mean New York Yasmar restaurants.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's more stuff to do definitely.
But there's also more tension.
There's also a,
you know,
the dealing with the overpopulation,
dealing with traffic.
You just like,
everybody's on edge.
I don't want to live somewhere where
everybody's on edge,
you know?
Yeah.
It makes,
it makes people a little bit.
Some people more creative.
It makes.
I think it makes for more interesting
people,
you know,
more people in the east coast are way
more interesting to me that people on
the west coast there were way funnier to
me.
Yeah.
Isn't it weird that the left sides of
the United States is more dangerous than
the right side,
but yet the right side as the angry or
people than the left side when it comes
to like the east coast versus West.
Mostly East Coast is more dangerous.
Like angry people.
You don't like the New York attitudes,
that Boston attitude toward it.
Gangsters.
You know?
East Coast is more aggressive and
aggressive,
but yeah,
that's the safer place to live.
But why you think of North Carolina?
Why is it a safer place?
Because the whole side,
we live on your like into the rural and
shit,
like the earthquakes and the volcanoes
and fucking like Sorta,
but you know what?
They have to deal with snow.
Snow's a mother,
so secrets of snow to snow makes people
a little more
more hostile in America at least.
I tried to explain away that,
that that like why people are so
aggressive in Boston and New York.
I always said,
what's the deal with that cold weather?
It gets you a little more tense,
but I think there's more to it than
that.
It's cold weather end overpopulation
together.
That's what makes douchey people because
in Canada people are so fucking Nice,
man.
They're so nice.
Well,
you know what,
that doesn't make sense either because
even in Toronto,
Toronto's a big ass city and people were
nice as fuck.
They're to Canada.
Maybe it's much higher.
Maybe it's when your body has too much
hydration,
you get angry.
I don't know what it is,
man.
It's so cute because Canada is
not a country that's living under the
shadow of this is government that's out
there trying to take over the world.
You know?
That's part of it too.
I mean we've.
That
that doesn't make up for America in the
fifties though,
or you know,
in the thirties or the forties,
they were pretty aggressive back then
too,
and even in the 18 hundreds you ever see
gangs of New York.
What it used to be allowed.
No Dude,
gangs in New York is an awesome movie.
You've never seen that.
Oh,
it's awesome to Daniel Day.
Lewis is one of those dudes that like
becomes whoever the fuck he's in that
movie.
He's a different dude when he does these
movies,
you know,
he's like one of those few guys that
really.
Russell Crowe can do that.
Gary Oldman can do the shit out of that.
You know?
He's one of those dudes that just
becomes a different dude when he's in
those.
Hmm.
Years.
There's,
there's that new Leonardo.
I'm moving to your.
See it shuts stutter islands.
Yeah.
I didn't like that one.
No,
no,
no.
I talked about it.
I was really good for like the first
hour or so.
And then I don't want to give away any
spoilers because some people haven't
seen it.
You haven't seen it either?
No.
I don't want to say you received the
beach with him in it or the island or.
I know that's like the cheesiest movie
ever,
but good fucking actor though.
He's another one.
He,
he gets into things like he's,
he's good.
You know.
It's,
you know what I heard that's a craft.
You know,
there's,
there's some cheese heads out there.
They're,
they're not doing anything special,
but there's a few like,
like God,
that's another thing that um,
that moved there,
said crazy heart.
What's the guy's name?
Jeff Bridges.
Jeff bridges that,
that's another guy.
He's the big Lebowski.
I mean,
he's just,
he's an amazing actor.
He's one of those dudes who just,
he gets into that fucking roll man.
He does it.
So Touche to answer some questions or
something of your body.
You seeing the movie during with the
fishes dream with the fishes as David
Arquette in it.
Really small budget,
low budget movie.
But one of the things is,
is like date,
this guy was dying and said he wanted to
do like his last list of things.
And one thing he did is he went naked
boy.
He went into this bowling alley in the
middle of night on Lsd and went bowling
naked with strippers.
And that scene right there to me is just
what would.
Is there any three things that you would
say if you knew you were about to die,
but you would definitely do like.
All right.
All you know,
everything's off.
I'm doing this now.
Have you ever thought about that?
No.
No?
Like I don't have anything.
No.
Have you ever seen the pyramids?
Yes.
Yeah.
I would like to see the pyramids,
but you know what?
I'm.
I can be okay without them.
I think being.
I mean I think I've seen so much of it
on DVD.
I mean,
I think yeah,
it would be really nice to go over there
and see it live for sure.
Definitely.
It will be spiritual feel like a
different vibe in the air or something.
No.
I know what you mean.
Yeah,
but I can be okay without saying that.
I mean I think it's really.
I would love to see a lot of things.
I would love to see the Congo,
but I don't want to go in there.
Right.
It's too scary.
But if you get.
When force fields come out,
would you go?
Would it be forced to have roads that
are first I want to make it a fucking
charge?
No,
not now.
You fuck with personal force field.
We're like,
oh,
you got a t and t force field.
What are you fucking crazy.
You're going to go to the Congo with at
and t personal have horizon.
Do not go overseas.
That's no,
no shit.
Right.
It's going to be like,
that's gonna be tied to a t and d one
Juju.
Like Dr Manhattan.
What?
Dr Manhattan.
Was that from the fucking.
Oh,
what is it?
What's that movie?
Watchman.
The watchman.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
I was not familiar with that comic book
before that movie came out.
It was good though.
It was on.
Ellen is Dr Manhattan.
I don't think I ever talked about this
with twitter.
When twitter first came out,
ellen tweeted like,
Hey,
go to this bus stop if you want to be on
the show,
but you have to dress up as a superhero.
Hurry.
And I was at the stoplight right next to
that.
That bus stop.
So I pull over and I'm fucking like
looking through my car.
Trying to find it head like some laundry
in there.
I had some clothes and I'm back pillow
and I found all these blue things and I
dressed up all in blue and I put this a
neck pillow on my head and I got in the
bus stop and I was on the Ellen show as
Dr Manhattan.
And one of the funniest things though
was I,
uh,
I took a sleeve of a blue coat and I put
through my zipper and I,
and I tied it at the end and put some
socks in it and stuff like that.
So it looked like I had this big wavy
Dick and nobody even saw it.
Like they didn't even understand that
that's what it was.
But if you watch it knowing that I'm
coming out on l and they're like,
let's introduce Dr Wong,
Mr Manhattan or whatever,
and I'm coming out with this swing video
of this song.
Uh,
there isn't,
but I will put a video up.
How do you not have that online?
Uh,
I think I do,
but it's on my facebook and god,
how dare you.
I'll put it on the masses.
The fucked up shit out right now.
I'll put a red band.com
or twitter home
red band dot Com.
Get Joe's philosophy of thinking.
That scene,
that scene,
the pyramids on TV is the same as real
life.
Oh Man.
I don't think it's the same as real
life.
I'm just saying if,
if there's only a few things I could do
before I died,
that wouldn't be my choice.
I'd be okay without saying it.
I would like to see it.
I'm one of the reasons why I haven't
done it is because first of all,
I don't have much time.
I travel so much for work.
I don't really have that much time to
travel outside of work.
It's not fun for me.
It's like I'm traveling all the time,
so like an extra trip to Egypt doesn't
sound exciting to me.
And then the other part about it is that
it's not that safe over there.
You know,
you've got to be.
It's tricky.
I don't want to have to sweat shit.
You know,
I saw the only ruins I've ever seen
where in Mexico I saw the Mayan ruins at
Chichen Itza,
which is a.
It was pretty humbling man and it's
really fascinating.
Just stand there and I do agree that
there's a big difference between
standing there in person,
you know,
and checking these things out than
watching a video or seeing it in
pictures.
Standing there in person was a pretty
flabbergasted,
but all I'm saying is I don't need to go
to Egypt.
I would like to.
Yes,
but I don't need to.
I can be okay
without doing that,
but it's.
I'm not saying that it's the same thing.
It's certainly not now,
but you can learn a lot of things about
certain places and really experienced
like how amazing and beautiful they are
just from dvds.
Like you really don't have to fucking.
You don't have to go to the Congo.
The Congo is so fucking dangerous.
Everything there is trying to kill you.
Everything there,
they got ants there that killed
elephants.
What did you hear me son.
They got ants that kill elephants.
They climb up the fucking elephant,
go into his ear and start eating his
brain while he's alive,
and they do that in surges.
They have these little monster ants to
climb inside and eat their fucking
brain,
and they're responsible for way more
deaths in Africa than any of the other
things.
Ants killed everything,
man.
They killed everything.
There's some monster,
crazy scary aunts and in Africa,
and that's not even for fuck all that.
What about the spiders that act as a
team?
There's no spiders anywhere in the world
that act impacts except the Congo and
they don't even know why,
but fucking deers get trapped in these
little tiny spider webs.
Deers get trapped.
These tiny spiders swarm on it like 100
wants and fuck them up.
They make these giant ass fucking webs.
They've realized that they're small and
in order to survive and stay alive,
they have to Jack bigger shit.
So they,
they fucking teamed up.
They get birds,
they get all kinds of shit.
It's fucking nuts,
man.
It is nuts.
And that's just spiders.
What about the fucking snakes?
There's all kinds of fucking snakes in
the Congo.
There's,
there's a chimpanzee in the Congo that's
six feet tall and they walk upright.
Sometimes they're called Bondo apes.
It sounds retarded.
It sounds totally ridiculous because
nobody ever tells you about it,
but they have photographs of these
things.
They got a picture of a dead one.
They have a different bone samples like
they've confirmed.
This is an actual real animal.
It has a crest on his head like a
gorilla does.
So it's a different animal.
It's a different species of chimpanzee
that's much larger.
And they call them lion killers.
That's what the locals call them and
they have fucking observed scientists
observed and photographed them eating a
dead Jaguar.
They don't know if they killed the
Jaguar,
but what the fuck they're eating a
Goddamn Jaguar.
That's why verizon personal force field
is important.
Very important.
But I would love to see all that,
you know,
but I don't want to go there.
Jesus Christ,
go to the Congo.
Just a mosquito will fuck the rest of
your life up.
You ever watched that show?
Uh,
the enemies inside us,
when people,
they always go swimming in Africa and
like fucking geniuses and shit gets in
their ear,
starts rotting away their brain,
you know,
like big giant tumors growing in their
head and it turns out massive worms that
they picked up an Africa seven years
ago.
Get the fuck out of Africa.
Are you crazy?
Everything's trying to kill you.
They're everything.
That scary math sounds like a good porn
to enemy inside you.
That's one of the things that parents
do.
They're really good at that.
They're really good at coming up with a
Jersey hoarder names.
Yeah.
They're pretty,
pretty creative when it comes to that.
What are the questions up in this bitch?
Yeah,
we're youtube that Bondo Apes,
man,
that thing will freak the fuck.
I twittered the neon Helen,
but I could only find it in torrent
right now,
but there's links from the torn.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Powerful torrent.
Somebody retweets it for me,
so it shows up on the use steering
chat,
so I want to see that with clash of the
titans.
Yeah.
I want to say that too.
That looks like a flag reviews though.
Really?
Yeah,
I heard it was shit.
Will they probably weren't high.
Yeah,
it's true.
I bet it's not smoking weed.
I didn't smoke weed for almost a week
into until recently.
Oh,
it discusses.
Are you aware that the internet came out
of CERN?
No,
I didn't know that.
Those are the people that are working on
the large Hadron collider.
Wow.
I thought the Internet came up.
Al Gore's butthole.
That wasn't it.
How did that even see?
Never really said Wiszniak started that.
Larry that would start this thing about
guard,
but he never really said that he
invented the Internet.
Right.
He helped work on the what became the
Internet,
but it was more like funding.
Right.
Pushed a bill through or some nonsense
guy pushing for it.
He might've said that he was one of the
people that help.
Did he ever say,
does anybody know?
I don't even want to look that up.
You don't want to fuck Al Gore.
I don't give a shit about Al Gore.
When I heard that,
how much money Al Gore's made from
climate research,
now I'm like,
what?
Al Gore has made an ass load of money
based on the idea that we are,
uh,
you know,
warming the earth with our bullshit and
we may very well been,
I don't know,
man,
but I do know that people get nutty
about that issue.
That's one of those weird issues.
These,
those right left issues are so strange
where people just start spouting out
shit and they don't.
They haven't really done the research
yet.
You know,
like there's a,
there's a good video.
The same guy that did this video,
uh,
with Sarah Pailin.
Don't remember the dude's name.
I'm going to find out though,
but he did a video where he went to a
Sarah Pailin book signing and then ask
these people like,
what do you feel about,
uh,
you know,
Sarah Pailin,
what really gets you excited about,
you know,
about her stance on the issues and no
one knew a fucking thing.
Like not no one had any idea what,
you know,
they were just like,
she's just,
she stands for,
you know,
down home values and I think she's the
best thing going,
she's getting back to real people,
like they're just saying nonsense and
you realize that people don't have to
fucking,
they don't have to,
you know,
make sense.
They just have to have a bunch of people
thinking that makes sense.
That's all you really need to have.
But this guy who did it with the tea
party people too,
I don't like,
I don't know fucking dude's name,
but uh,
he made this video and it was,
it was just genius Shit,
man.
You know,
and people just think everybody just,
they just take a side that their team
takes,
you know what I mean?
And it's like there's US versus them
nonsense.
It's just so crazy.
And when it comes to global warming,
when it comes to healthcare,
it's like,
you know,
everyone has a very typical and
predictable,
what are you doing?
Let's come back to that typical and
predictable a stance on things.
And very rarely do people stray outside,
you know,
the either or ideologies left or right.
You know,
I hate when people ask me,
are you a Democrat or Republican?
Like what are you talking about?
It's a nonsense game.
It's all nonsense.
There's no fucking Democrats and there's
no Republican says stop it.
It's all nonsense.
It's been nonsense since the beginning.
It's just a,
it's a bunch of fucking red tape and,
and,
and fucking just complications.
A bunch of shit piled up together to,
to control either or.
No,
the idea that there really are democrats
and they're really.
I mean,
look at what Obama's doing.
He's doing the exact same shit.
Bush.
Did you just doing a little,
a few things different socially and all
of a don't ask,
don't tell.
But when you win the Nobel Peace Prize,
he still sent 30,000
more people to a war that nobody wants.
I mean,
do they really know more than ever?
Can you tell me,
man,
dude,
it's like talking sports and to me,
don't you think that if you just don't,
it doesn't to me.
Well you should.
I don't think you should spend that much
time.
Who cares what it is?
Fuck that guy.
Fuck it all.
It's all stupid.
Just negative.
If you really think about how fucked up
this whole United States government is,
but I mean you think that it's.
Is it possible to do anything about it?
I think if it is what the ways you're
going to do something about it is not
necessarily influencing people with
thought and changing these people's
opinions before they get into this
terrible situation of doing fuck up.
Things that are not benefiting the
people I think.
I think you have to affect them.
You have to let them know that they're.
They're not going to live forever.
I think there's people way better than
that than me,
so instead of worrying and spending my
stress on it,
I didn't even though man,
to me it's just like another crazy
reality show that I have to watch.
You know,
like it's,
it's like they attack each other where
it's so ridiculous.
You can't believe anyone can't.
Everyone's fucking fake.
It's all bullshit.
Craziest that Fox News is real,
that that's a real.
I mean that is like some parody crazy
too that Fox news is a real show.
Fox News is like if there was like a TV,
a movie from the eighties with like Bill
Murray in it,
some sort of a parody that would be like
the right wing,
you know,
Rah Rah fucking truth organization.
That would be the network that they
would make fun of in a parody movie.
And that's what's really going on man.
And the parody movie,
that would be like some really hot
blonde chick who was mean as fuck,
you know,
like all those hot blonde chicks on Fox
News,
they all look like they had this mean
face the other hot as fuck.
But they've got this.
They'll fucking yell at you man.
You know what I mean?
They,
when they,
when they interrogate dudes on the show,
when they give people a hard time on
Charlotte and cut people off,
like they're like the stern right wing,
like Arion blue,
wide hot bitches,
you know,
that's perfect for like a Bill Murray
movie.
And those checks would be real horny and
somebody be fucking.
Would they be screaming out Nazi shit or
something?
You know what I mean?
That,
that would be in the movie.
I mean,
they really are.
It is really.
His life is like a movement.
Life is like as ridiculous as a movie
more almost unbelievable,
right?
I mean,
what,
when you think about like a plot in a
movie that you know,
is,
uh,
is predictable and annoys you,
you know,
life is way more,
way more wacky than that.
You know what I mean?
Like that Ted Haggard thing with that
guys,
the,
you know,
the religious guy gets caught doing gay
sex and crystal Meth,
you know,
the fucking John Edwards thing where he
gets busted and his wife is dying and
he's having this baby with this other
woman and this,
this craziness that goes on with people,
you know,
all of it.
Altogether.
It's like we are the nuttiest movie of
all time.
You know,
we're the krays movie ever,
don't you think?
Yeah.
What the fuck is this folks?
Where,
where is this going?
You know,
we're all just living and until our
bodies shutoff
and we don't even address it,
we don't even stop and really think
about it.
I mean,
you know,
on Oprah,
everybody wants to tell you how you can
better decorate your living room with
fucking Feng Shui and you know,
the,
the current
consciousness of our culture,
you know,
is not at all focused on the really big
questions.
Like the really freaky fucking
Like the fact that how little we think
about space,
you know,
the little we think about the fact that
at any time some crazy shit can happen.
There can be in a hyper Nova and the
next galaxy and we'd be wiped out
instantly if this is all real and random
and easily can happen.
Now it's.
Is there any money in campfires like
make a campfire?
No,
because you'd be really good at
campfires somehow.
You could,
if there was any money in like a
campfires,
like,
hey,
we're going to have a campfire tonight.
If you could get any money from that,
and he goes,
rogue is going to be at this campfire.
What don't you think you'd be like,
the best person be a bunch.
Would want to take pictures of me with
their fists up.
I can get the.
Imagine you would like a job corps light
in in big coolers and they be like,
Yo Bro,
who's going to be GSP?
Stop running this like,
man,
we're talking about ancient
civilizations,
Bro.
Oh fuck.
Those ancient faggots.
It would appear.
I bought the worms.
Growing worms.
Anyways,
this is what you stopped campfires
instead of comedy in it of Campfire
night where you're in the middle of a
campfire,
you all bring your tens and your hang
out and smoke weed and do mushrooms and
you're in the middle because it's just
like doing like what you're doing now or
stand up.
Kind of like by kind of like a metal
talking campfire guy.
That sounds like a great way to get
annoyed by hippies.
True.
You've got to deal with a lot of stinks
bringing her.
Monica.
Monica is a bunch of stinky dudes that
need favors.
That's going to be annoying.
There'll be annoying.
That's the number one problem with
marijuana is hippies.
God Damn.
Some of them are annoying.
Can you imagine the smell?
The hackey sack convention?
Yeah.
Occurred occurred though Petrouli and
hacky sack sweats.
Hippies.
You know,
the,
the idea behind it is great.
The problem is a lot of the people that
fall into that,
that mode of thinking,
they're all fucked up,
you know,
they're lazy too.
That's another problem with hippies.
A lot of them are fucking lazy,
you know,
a lot of them are always broke and
always want you to help him out.
Oh,
it's like,
it's a drain.
Like if you have hippies for friends,
it's like some of them are just
constantly asking you for favors and it
gets so annoying.
You know?
It's like you have to cut them off as
friends.
Like you're just always needy.
Fuck,
like,
can't your Goddamn shit together.
You know?
That's like,
how many dudes do you know that are like
that,
that they're like always broke.
I,
come on,
man,
you gotta get your shit together.
Better out here though,
back in Ohio is completely different.
Way More brokester in Ohio,
you know,
at least out here.
And most people I didn't know or you
know,
kind of like have jobs like glassware,
you know,
where like comics and people that aren't
the people that are in your circle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
what man was living a regular life,
regular jobs.
It's very hard for people to do after
awhile because you know,
we're sold this bill of goods that all
you need to be happy is,
you know,
find something that pays well and that
we're,
you know,
steady work.
Doesn't matter if you don't love it,
you still have your free time,
you know,
you,
you go through it and yeah,
you know,
you move up the ladder and you make more
money in,
you buy a bigger house and then he
fucking die.
You know,
there's no,
there's no end to that.
You know.
And for some idea,
for some reason were sold at there is,
were sold that we're doing something,
we're working hard and the eventually
it's going to pay off.
It doesn't pay off.
He just die.
You know,
everybody just dies.
So you have to enjoy this.
This is what you have enjoyed right now,
and it's not,
it's not possible for everybody.
There's been a lot of times in your life
and in my life that we weren't enjoying
things,
you know,
I wasn't,
I wasn't enjoying life.
I didn't have Dr.
Limos,
that Limo.
What was that like?
Have you ever.
Did you ever do anything famous or
anyone famous or anyone that would like,
wow,
I,
Frank Sinatra is in the back of my limo.
I almost got to drive a Stevie Ray
Vaughan,
but he wouldn't take limos.
He would only take a cab.
Is that like the worst day for you?
Were like,
I'm getting drunk tonight?
Almost was like,
yeah,
I probably would have panicked.
I probably killed him.
It would probably be me that killed him
and not the a helicopter.
I was um,
I was a huge TV Rayvon fat.
So if I really got to drive him in a
car,
I'd probably panicked.
I was only 19 years old.
I was an idiot,
you know,
maybe I was 20,
20.
I was watching,
I wasn't at home.
So yeah,
I think I moved out of my parent's house
when I was 20,
so I think I was 21 when I was doing
that.
I was watching that a driver when we
were out of town in New York.
I was watching the limo driver and he
had to like sit in his car like the
whole day he was having like a full on
like his wife with his wife,
just having conversations and I felt bad
for these guys because they're like gone
for chunks at a time.
It's a hard job and you know what's
really hard about it is the hours they
want you to work crazy hours.
I mean,
and the way they would put it to me
though when I,
when I first got the job there that was
saying,
you know what a lot of you guys,
you're going to go to school and you
know you're going to try to make a
living and you've got to realize it's a
hard job for us out there.
You know,
it's hard to get jobs.
You look at Mike over there,
he's been working here for 10 years.
He doesn't bust his ass,
he sits down at a nice Kyle Day and he
makes $60,000
a year.
Okay,
that's real money.
That's what they said to me.
And I was sitting there going,
oh my God,
do you know how many hours that God
works?
He doesn't have a life.
Like he gave away his whole life for
$60,000
a year.
Like this fucking guy was literally no
bullshit working 16 hours every day.
He was always there and uh,
I looked at him and I was like,
okay,
you got tricks on,
you know,
you're,
you're doing the wrong thing,
man.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
But no,
that ain't easy man.
If you got a job,
if you're only doing it for a few hours
a day,
you know,
if you're doing it like a regular job,
but it ain't bad really.
If you have good clients,
you know,
what are you're doing just sitting down
and drive it and that's no big deal,
but they want you to work crazy hours.
I was doing 40 hours a week and they
were,
they were adamant they wanted me to put
it more out.
So I'd work eight hours.
I would work eight hours and I would
want to go home and they'll go eight
hours,
just nothing like it with is 12 and he's
still waiting for his next pickup and be
like,
for Fuck Mikey and fuck you.
I worked eight hours.
Get me out of here stupid.
I don't want any more hours.
I got,
I got work to do.
I had a Gig at a,
uh,
some fucking bar,
you know,
one of these comedy things and I had to
leave work for the Gig.
And um,
when I was there on the way there,
they switched the gigs,
but they said,
oh,
we're gonna send you to this one
instead.
I think there was like a,
I think it was probably Boston comedy at
the time because like a booking agency
and they had a bunch of these little
gigs,
you know,
like in weird little places,
you drive like an hour and a half and it
was like a little sports bar.
And then have a little stage and he
would go on stage and sometimes they
would switch.
You say,
hey this guy is going to go with him
because he doesn't have a car,
so why don't you go to this place
instead?
So that's what I did.
And so this asshole called up the
fucking the bar where I was supposed to
be because he asked me like,
you're leaving out.
I'm like,
I got a Gig.
So he calls up the fucking bar and then
the next day says,
you lying motherfucker.
You told me you were working.
Like,
like,
like dude,
I work eight hours and yeah I got
switched.
I had tell him the whole story to keep
my job.
And he had to call this bar
right after working eight hours.
Right.
He said I used to wash windows with me
and this girl was the worst.
She would have a little girl and hold
the ladder and I would have to climb
like four stories up or while stone out
of my mind and try to clean windows,
like bending over and stuff.
You doing that because it was like $12
an hour and in Ohio,
$12 an hour is amazing and we were
actually doing it stoned.
Huh?
While we're doing that,
it's been washing windows.
What else are you going to do?
Like wash windows and be sober was the
way the fuck up jet a letter like that?
God Damn.
That'd be terrifying.
But sometimes you just go to a house and
you got,
Oh fuck,
why'd I get stoned?
You know,
you look at the house.
Oh No.
And anyways,
my boss,
this old lady said that me or the girl
who was my girlfriend at the time that
we worked together a stole something
from her house and we got fired.
That boss is yelling and screaming at us
and it's like,
like I wasn't even going to pay us any
paycheck stuff.
Then a week later they,
he called us back.
Oh,
by the way,
she found what she was looking for her
and she apologizes and I'm like,
oh,
well yeah,
me and this girl fired and kick ass.
Do you remember what it's like to have a
boss?
Like have bosses?
Oh,
most of my life,
whereas this waiting tables like shit,
the idea that someone who is above you
in a work organization that gets treated
like shit,
that is one of the worst feelings in the
world.
I did construction most of the time.
I did construction.
I did it under nice guys or y'all never
had any real bad bosses,
but I did have one bad bosses.
A landscaper guy was an asshole.
Just just an asshole.
Just not friendly,
not nice.
Wanted you to always work harder.
Never had a smile,
never appreciated your work.
Would give your money.
At the end of the week we'd like to look
like you didn't even deserve this.
Why you motherfucker.
I work for you all week.
You cunt.
I worked all week,
all day,
all week exhausted at the end of every
day.
Just so tired.
Push the lawnmower in the hot sun and
digging holes for people and doing
whatever the fuck they want you to do.
It's labor,
you know,
and this motherfucker didn't give a shit
like I couldn't imagine that.
I couldn't imagine having someone to
work for me and having them do all this
stuff and then treating them like shit,
like,
you know,
it was a few,
you don't fucking deserve this.
Like really like what kind of a fucking
human being,
you know,
make someone work hard and doesn't
appreciate that,
you know,
that's terrible and it sets you up in
life to start thinking of work like
that,
you know,
so you never think you're going to do
anything with your time that's going to
be actually fun.
You don't think it's even possible,
you know,
I did.
I washed dishes.
That was the worst was pretty bad.
But on the grill the grill was way worse
for my acne because I do fucking
cheeseburgers and I was a lazy fucking
kid.
I didn't wash my face and I was like a
teenager.
So I was getting all these visits anyway
and it just,
my whole face was just a fucking
festival.
I stopped working there.
I moved up to Papa Ginos to the Little
Papa Ginos for while,
and then I started getting real jobs.
Then I started teaching martial arts.
You had,
the best part was I was a projectionist
for like eight years and managers and
movie theaters and stuff like that,
but working in the movie theater
industry,
it's so fun.
Especially when was the projectionist
job is like,
you know,
thread.
The movie is almost like an art,
just like threading this film through
this one machine and they the perfect to
start the movie.
You sit there and watch it with
headphones on or I just like go out back
smoke weed,
you know.
It was just like,
that was my job and it's so crazy with
the coolest
times ever after a show wants back of
the old laptop and Houston.
This was right when the Blair witch
project came out and these kids came to
the show and then after they came to the
show,
we all went out and we watched a Blair
witch at the theater.
It was really late at night because
there was like a show at the laptop.
The laptop was like 11:00
at night and it went on until like 1:30,
so it was like 2:00
in the morning.
By the time we get out and these kids
opened up the theater and turned it on,
did everything just for us.
So it was like me and them and you know,
my friend Chris Mcguire and like one
other guy from the comedy club and we
all watched player,
which yeah,
that's those days they fucking hook x
boxes up to it and it's all digital
agenda.
Wagner's like anytime you want to come,
like they do it on the imax screen.
Had a universal there and play xbox on
this.
Perfect.
Steve,
my head might explode.
Imagine that quake fucking head might
explode.
I can't do it.
I'm scared of quake dude.
To this day.
I thought about playing it the other
day.
I got scared
by the way,
dude.
Your dvds out to you should use a plug
that and my short movies on there
talking monkeys and Columbus and uh,
it's pretty cool to watch it.
Yeah.
The dvds out.
So if you saw the special,
uh,
on tv,
it's that.
And there's a lot of,
uh,
it's uncensored and then there's a lot
of q and a footage just like five
minutes or something.
It's a lot,
it's like,
I don't remember how many minutes it is,
but it's,
it's a lot of q and a and I do that in
most of the shows.
I just,
I always feel like,
uh,
it makes it more fun,
you know,
it's one thing to have like a normal
comedy show and I know you want that
too.
But uh,
I think it's also fun to just shoot the
shit together,
you know,
and me make fun of things,
with a microphone.
And so the end of the show,
uh,
I always have that kind of q and a type
thing except
it's almost becoming bits because they
want to ask the same questions and that
kind of sexist to Vcu twice and you're
getting the same questions.
Then it's like,
well,
I know I
tried.
Some things have to be answered the same
way,
like the DMT thing.
There's no other way to answer it,
you know,
when I try to explain that there's no
other way to explain it.
I have to explain it the best way I can
explain it.
And that's,
that's that.
And it's going to sound same way every
time.
The only
way.
It's funny,
it's if it's,
if I do it like that anyway,
there is a bit.
So they don't want to do about that.
I'm going to put that on my next,
a comedy special,
that description of it.
So that way nobody ever asked me again
because they know what it is,
you know,
like,
you know what I mean?
It's like you're not going to yell out
DMT and then like,
I'll just say go to itunes,
bitch,
you know,
at a certain point in time it's like I
can't keep talking about the same things
over and over again.
And that's one of them that's been.
Ever since I've did conversations about
it on a Jim Breuer show,
I hate the fight.
Who's going to win versus who?
Like you said that a million times,
don't ask.
Who Do you think about this point in
this fight?
Who's going to win?
Well,
no.
I know people like to talk about five,
so they just like to talk about it.
That's like baseball,
baseball.
Well,
there's a certain amount of people that
just like that,
they just like to talk about it and you
know,
I appreciate the fact that,
you know,
they,
they liked me as a commentator and they
want to know my take on things,
you know,
and I understand that.
But you know,
I,
I can't.
First of all,
I wouldn't give a prediction.
The only time I would ever give a
prediction that something's ridiculous,
you know,
like,
you know is going to fight my mom.
I'm going to say,
oh my mom's fucked.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I'm saying?
But unless it's like that I don't get
predictions and those fights don't occur
in the UFC,
the UFC fights 99 percent of them.
Like I'm like,
what the fuck is going to happen here
with this,
this,
this.
I can see a lot of scenarios taking
place and there's neither one of them
is,
is definitely for sure.
So I would never say this guy's gonna do
this and that.
When I,
when I hear guys,
especially the guys that have never
fought in anything before the they just
sports podcasts or type dudes.
And they're talking shit about fighters
and like this guy doesn't belong in
there with them and it's going to be,
you know,
easy work for that guy and you know,
I look for him to knock him out in the
first round.
Like,
what are you talking about?
You're just making some crazy prediction
about what the fuck is going to happen
in a fight between two skilled men that
are more than capable of smashing each
other.
You Zig when you should zag.
Somebody cracks one the knees give out
and you've got a flashlight in your face
when you wake up.
That shit is normal.
That's par for the course that happens
all the time.
You know?
I mean people who never thought they
were going to get knocked out,
getting knocked out.
It happens all the time.
People get submitted when they were
winning easily.
You know guys who guys who no one ever
thought we'd get submitted.
That dude in the wec recently got so
many.
Karen,
Karen dare obedient.
I think his name is bad ass fucking
grappler.
And he fucked up.
He left an arm and then this dude took
his arm bar.
You can't predict there's a power outage
at the last use right off on,
or was it a.
I tweeted that area and he plugged a
vibrator and backstage and that crushed
the circuit breaker power adapter of it,
but she tweeted that and that it was
actually my butt plug,
my vibrating but blog.
So she made me feel really bad about
that.
But uh,
yeah,
it was right before Roy Nelson flood.
Stephan struve right before they went to
fight the power went out.
That's never happened before.
It was totally a.
Did you see area one has her own shirt
that they sell at uscs is now.
It's just,
it's just her.
I'm going to get one of you should you
wearing.
That's right.
Put it on backwards.
You know what I'm talking about?
I don't know what you're talking about.
If you put it on backwards in her face
and touching you,
she's hugging you and then you put it
onto barry white.
Oh No.
Oh,
that's who is not white.
Who was a chef from south park.
You guys see this south park,
it's about medical marijuana.
I know,
man,
I'd have to see so many of them.
I have a bunch of them saved up on the
DVR.
South Park is the best ever.
No,
no.
Show has been consistently funny for
this long South Park.
That's the greatest show in the history
of the world.
They're the meanest.
When they go after somebody,
they're the,
like the,
the funniest,
the most fucked up it.
There's no show that's even close to is
fucked up.
That show that they did were um,
Paris Hilton had the whore off with the
gay dude and he stuffed Paris Hilton up
his ass.
Like,
oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
That was good.
Yeah.
They're just so funny.
They're like,
they'll take your place.
You like,
there's no way they're going to go
fucking believe you did that.
You know,
they just do it consistently over and
over and over again.
It's the one,
the number one show for me,
like,
guaranteed.
I'm going to love it.
I want to hang with trey parker so bad.
Maybe he will try to fuck,
you know,
I think um,
I think,
uh,
he's probably one of the funniest guys
ever.
As far as creativity,
I don't think any,
anybody has ever put out as much stuff.
As prolific as he is.
No one has ever put out as much.
Funny stuff.
Is that guy and the other guy too?
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know who's writing it.
You've seen the Cannibal who writes it?
Who,
who's writing?
She writes everything.
Everything.
I think he just helps once in a while,
but it's mostly because we don't want to
give them credit.
I know from what I understand,
my trade just locked himself in his
office and just mad writer and he's
always changing stuff and there's no
show that's been like that.
I mean think about what they're doing.
They have these little corny looking
animated dudes that they're,
you know,
they're really,
really,
really crude.
Now the images are so crude and it's
really easy to do,
you know,
as far as that kind of stuff is.
And then they,
they consistently go after more shit.
And I'm sorry,
was that.
I was going to answer it something,
trevor.
They don't have a team of writers.
Sorry.
This guy says they have a team around
him,
but he knows the people that worked
there and he's actually been there
before.
I think they had a team of writers at
one point for like a season or something
or health writer help,
but from from my understanding now it's
really just trained.
Yeah.
Everybody says this week's episode,
Groovy girly.
Everybody says that it's the greatest
episode over.
Pretty ridiculous.
There's one part about it is we're so
good,
man,
and they're so good.
It's humbling.
It's humbling how much that God has put
out.
You know,
you think about the stuff that you've
done,
like how productive you've been over
your life and you see what that guy's
done like Jesus Christ.
I just wished that team
America to would happen because that
wasn't.
That was still.
It was the hardest movie ever for every
one of my.
I think that's top five.
Maybe.
Maybe the first one.
There was no,
no movie ever.
The first time I saw made me laugh that
hard.
No movie,
no movie even came close.
That was the second time.
It wasn't as funny to me,
but the third time,
I mean it's just like it's not,
it's the third time was just as good as
the secretary and I still do that and it
was maybe funnier than the first time I
saw.
I forgot how funny it was too close to a
lot of it was shocking.
Yeah,
at twice,
you know,
wanting them again five years later to
do that.
I didn't enjoy it.
I didn't enjoy it the second time,
but I loved it so much the first time,
you know,
there's certain things that you can't
see twice,
but certain things you can see over and
over and over again.
You know,
it's funny.
Comedies are very funny thing like that,
you know,
like why is like really bad stuff like
roadhouse or like showgirls or something
like that.
Like the more you see it,
the funnier it is,
you know,
you could see it like a bunch of times
and it gets funnier because he started
knowing the script of it and you want to
act it out.
There's some movies that are so
ridiculous that it's just going,
oh,
this one right here,
Howard.
The duck.
This is Tuckey.
That movie.
What was it called?
The adventures in babysitting.
Nobody needs this.
This,
this was recommended to me.
I think we've talked about this.
If you want a bad movie,
go get this.
The room.
It's fucking true.
Genius.
Don't watch it by yourself.
It's not as fun.
But if you watch it with some friends
that are funny,
it's a genius,
geniusly bad movie.
Apparently they have screenings in
Hollywood,
the room,
and they'd play that movie and people
get there and they,
they,
they quote the words because they,
everyone knows the words and it's like a
sort of a rocky horror picture thing.
It's that bad.
It's you want to borrow it?
Well,
I can just make a cop.
I mean,
but.
And I just look at it on my computer.
Let me just look at it on my computer
real quick.
I just want to know.
Let's not even do this online.
I don't even want people to get the
wrong impression here.
Everyone likes fight club.
You know what man?
I'll tell you what,
I didn't like fight club.
I'd liked it.
I liked it for awhile and then when I
found out that the two dudes were
actually one dude,
I was like,
what?
Fuck you man.
I didn't want it anymore.
So I liked it up until the end movie
rules.
Dude.
I didn't like it after I found out that
they were supposed to be two dudes
inside because he's punching himself in
the face and yes,
that was way more believable.
The problem is you're seeing a bunch of
shit in this movie.
That didn't really happen.
It's like the style of it,
the visual Shitty to me is like,
yeah,
that sucks because it's not what I want
it to be,
but everything else along the way was so
amazing that you can't.
It required a suspension of disbelief
that I wasn't willing to give it.
When all of a sudden you're telling me
that everything I saw was just his
imagination.
So this entire movie,
what was real out of this fucking movie,
because in the movie I saw there was two
different people and if if one part of
it was
absolutely a figment of his imagination,
what the fuck?
What about the rest of it?
How much?
How do I know what I'm watching anymore?
Now I'm watching nonsense.
Now you have the shitty plot device
where you can say,
oh,
he was just a dream.
Oh,
he's gone crazy.
This is what's really happening.
He's hitting himself and I'm like,
what?
So what has really happened?
This guy's been sitting around hating
himself.
There's been no real fighting.
What's really going on?
I think he just don't like seeing Brad
Pitt get hurt is a part of me.
You know what I mean?
Sloan.
Yeah.
The.
That's another funny part about that
moving.
You know that everybody's like,
liking,
enjoying,
getting the fuck beat out of them.
Yeah.
That's great.
I love it.
I would hope that that's not the case in
real life.
I hope there is nothing.
The real fight clubs like that,
like those old videos we used to see
about the fights in the yards,
the,
what are they called,
where there's like gang fights almost
over in Russia.
The Russian gang fights.
That's the same.
That's a fight club as well.
That's like a gang war.
Youtube.
Russian fights.
Russian soccer.
Thug fight.
Yeah.
Soccer fights.
They beat the fuck out of each other.
We've talked about that on there before.
That's.
Yeah,
those guys are nuts.
Russians.
There's a there.
A different breed song that's a hardy
race.
I'm affected as video,
so the Russians,
they loved the Bra size.
My Fan.
Norm Mcdonald.
Huge Fan.
Normally Donald's one of my favorite
comedians.
Each fucking hilarious.
Norm.
Macdonald is a very unique dude.
There's something really just funny
about him.
Go canoeing with him to.
To him about anything.
He's one of those dudes.
Just want to talk to.
I want to fight club to be a buddy film.
Hey,
fuck you man.
Fuck you hector.
While you got some crazy shit going on
with your name.
Dang goose,
esquire.
Wow.
I like your avatar though.
That's pretty dope.
Blinking third eye,
your crafting internet hacker.
You have.
I seen Donnie Darko.
Yeah,
I liked that a lot.
I thought that was an interesting
little.
Yeah,
I see it.
It was pretty interesting,
man.
Donnie Darko,
and don't get me wrong,
I love fight.
I mean if I had to see fight club again,
I would watch it up until the moment.
I would watch it up until the moment
where you find out it's two people not
to shut it off because I liked it up
until that,
you know,
just.
I don't like that.
That's what I liked about.
Didn't like about shutter island.
I don't like when you say,
oh,
it was all trek,
you know,
don't,
don't give me that.
I don't want to hear it.
That's nonsense.
Show me a real goddamn moment,
you know?
That's why I like the Avatar was so
cool.
I have a feeling lost my face up.
I'm thinking the last recent episodes.
It's interesting,
but it's also like this could get really
bad,
bad that it could.
Like it has the potential to be ending
in a way that you're just like,
are you kidding me?
I think this year it just seems silly,
leaping back and forth and time.
No,
just one.
Once they hit the nuclear bomb and went
back in time,
I was like,
what is happening?
What's going on?
Shut up.
You can't just.
Nuclear jumped back and forth through
time,
you know,
stop it.
Just stop it.
I need more.
I need more from you than that.
I need a little more than you blow off a
nuclear weapon and we go back in time.
That's so stupid.
It was just,
it's too dumb.
And then where are we now?
We're in 1977.
What do we do?
Well,
you know,
you would be shitting your pants.
Come on.
Fuck.
We're stuck in 77.
No Internet.
You know,
even refrigerators sucked back then.
Nothing was good that the cars were all
shitty.
The brakes were up.
Barely stopped for anything.
Dude.
It sucked back then.
Everything sucked.
It would suck.
If you had to live back at 77.
Fuck that.
It would suck to accounting back.
Yeah.
They would shoot you if they so weed on
you.
We was totally illegal back then.
I have not seen Michael Rupert's film
collapse,
but I heard it's really good.
That guy scares the shit out of me.
Netflix.
Watch it.
He's one of those end of the world.
Dudes is collapse on Netflix.
Sure is fine.
I thought it was only out in the movies
or something.
I don't know.
Find out google that shit's collapse at
ups.
Probably some fucking nine slash 11
shit,
isn't it Michael?
Rupert Shit is A.
I think it's all about peak oil and he's
the guy that exposed the CIA or selling
drugs in movies.
Theater.
Still a DVD unknown.
Let's check out
the rest of the questions we have here
on the message board because it was a
bunch of them up here.
I'm like I said we.
We had have stopped last week because I
had a staph infection.
I had a little.
We should mention our friend outlawed.
Did we talk about that past?
The good friend outlaw from Joe's
message board has passed and he was a
great guy and we all love him very much
and really much thought to his wife.
Yeah,
much much love.
He was a really fun guy.
He was a dude that was a,
all my message board from the beginning.
Really.
I can't remember when he was never
there.
I mean,
I don't remember a time.
There was one time where he,
um,
he took off for awhile and uh,
I called them at home.
I got his,
uh,
information from somebody I call them at
home and I found out that his brother
had,
uh,
died recently and he had some,
some real serious family issues and he
was very depressed and um,
you know,
I talked to him and he was,
it was,
it was nice to know that he was okay
physically,
but he was real sad and then he came
back and eventually became his old self
again and he was just one of the
funniest posters,
man.
Dude was so,
like quick,
really witty and apparently according to
his wife he had always wanted to be a
standup comedian.
And that's one of the reasons why he
liked to hang out on my board because he
got to chance to like really be an
online comedian,
you know?
I mean,
that's like a real thing.
Now,
what we've talked about this before,
there are dudes
and message boards are like,
they're,
they're comedy stage.
You know,
like you're a good example of that.
You're,
I,
I consider you,
I mean you've done standup comedy a few
times,
but I consider you like an internet
comedian because you make these little
videos that are funny and you've put
them up on the Internet.
Well the problem is it's just like a,
you spend so much time at five hours,
you're spending a ton of hours just you
can get three to five minutes in front
of eight people.
I could spend the same amount of time,
make a video that thousands.
We'll see.
So it's like,
why would I want to do it on stage when
I could do the same thing on the
Internet and get $50,
million times more people seeing it.
Right?
And then eventually,
like I said,
with the red thing,
if you get enough people to see your
shit on the Internet,
you can develop like an immigrant
community.
I could go on and then you can go do a
show,
you know?
And that's what the kind of shit that
already really needs to take advantage
of because Ari has a name.
I mean,
he's been opening up for me for years.
Thousands of people have seen it because
of that.
And then he's been on the Jim Norton
show,
a down and dirty with Jim Norton and
he's got a lot of clips on the Internet
and he's been on opiod.
Anthea with me a bunch of times.
He was on the last time when I was
there.
So he's got enough stuff happening that
he should have like a community.
And so it's just a matter of putting it
together.
That's why it's so much better now than
it's ever been before for comedians.
And my message board is one of the best
parts about it.
And this dude outlaw was one of the best
parts about my message board.
He was a great guy.
He was really funny and he was,
uh,
just,
we,
we got a chance to hang out with them in
real life a few times once way back in
Houston,
way,
way back in the day.
It was how many years ago was at seven,
seven years ago and then again recently
last year he came to Dallas and what are
one or two other times other than that
to at least one,
but I can remember
one of the saddest things for me is
going to his facebook page.
His and his photos.
I forgot for Christmas last year.
I think for Christmas I sent them a
photo of me shaving my chest going,
Ooh,
not really shaving my chest but like a
photo of me and just as a joke because
that's how our relationship all were.
What was on the Internet,
like photoshops back and forth,
you silly photos and stuff.
And so like then I went to his facebook
and he has that on his facebook page and
I'm like,
oh that fucking photo for caterpillar.
That
was one of the cool things about the
message board is like,
you know,
we have like these online friends,
there really are online friends.
Some of them you never meet.
Some of them they're just that just
exist online.
And as long as your personality is cool
and you're friendly and you're funny,
you know,
you eventually get into the whole mix
there,
you know,
and that's what's encouraged funniness
and personality and an openness and the,
the idea,
you know,
that,
you don't have to fucking get in fights
with everybody you talk to online and
that if you do say something to
somebody,
a better be funny,
you know,
you're going to be a Douche,
but sounds like it should be really
funny,
you know.
And it's nice to have something like
that and,
you know,
it's nice to get a chance to meet cool
people that I probably would never meet
in real life like you or like outlaw you
or like,
you know,
Tony Z or,
I mean,
there's a lot of people now and there's
a lot of people that we've,
uh,
we've met online.
Bad Bobby,
you know,
it was really cool guys.
And I look forward to seeing you when I,
when I'm in town and I see him,
it's fun to hang with johnny rotten and
johnny rotten and yeah,
Jane Flower and her husband Henry,
you know,
let me say this,
a bunch of people that we met that are
really cool,
you know,
and it's,
it's,
it's a nice thing,
you know,
to have cultivated,
and I'm just happy that we got a chance
to hang out with this guy and I'm,
I'm,
I'm happy that uh,
we were in his life and that he took
pleasure in hanging out on my message
board and one of the best artist I know
too.
And it's crazy that he wasn't making
millions from his art.
Yeah,
he was,
he was a really creative guy.
Just,
you know,
first of all he was in Oklahoma and it
didn't feel like you had a lot of
opportunities around them,
you know,
all the time.
He just didn't feel like that many
things were,
uh,
available to him.
But he was a great guy.
Man.
Sucks.
Really does suck.
And he was fairly young.
Right.
How old is he?
My Age,
35,
so I'm kind of paranoid.
Scared now.
I've been eating Broccoli a lot lately.
I've been eating radishes,
radishes.
This guy will.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I've been cleaning up my diet a lot
lately.
I've been eating a lot more shit.
It's important to take care of your
health man.
And people don't appreciate that respect
that it's so easy to eat shitty.
It tastes good,
you know,
tastes good.
Eat fucking cheeseburgers with shit
sauce.
And then we always give a hard time
about it.
And he's
was.
Did you see the photo?
He twitted when you,
when you guys were in North Carolina,
have the barbecue,
have no of his uh,
what he ate that night?
No,
it was like potato chips.
MNMS beef jerky.
Ho hos like,
look at the photo.
It's on his twitter and backslash.
Ari Shaffir.
He does put away some junk food dude.
It was like,
all right.
That right there is like nipple cancer,
you know,
he killed them.
Charlotte.
I've had a really good set and try to
blow it up.
He was really good.
Cool.
He was in New York doing going up a lot
in New York.
Yeah,
you're,
it's pretty cool.
But never lived there.
Thinking about living there and just
thinking about I'm making a movie.
That's crazy.
People maybe be good for him,
you know,
maybe do something totally different.
Mix it up,
you know,
that's a,
that's a crazy that I have never
experienced in my life to be in a head
different head space.
I used to log in,
I liked you want to go back there a
little bit,
but part of it is just I know people
there and you know,
and I liked her for a quick jolt.
Get in there and get out of there.
You know,
I love going on opiod Anthony.
I love meeting my old pool plan.
Frowns.
I'd be an alcoholic immediately looming.
It seems like that's the only thing to
do.
And plus when we came back off the plane
in California after they're just seeing
nature scene,
grassy fields and trees,
I'm like,
oh my God,
I didn't see any of that when I was in
New York.
This is the perfect time to be driving
around California.
It's right after you.
Yeah,
everything's green if it sounds gay,
but when I'm getting the mail and it
smells like roses,
you're just like,
wow,
this is so much better to shit.
There's.
There's something to be said definitely
for that and there's definitely
something to be said.
It's not natural to live stack 70 people
on top of each other.
They've done like those population
density studies with rats and they found
that if they have a certain amount of
rats in a box,
everyone's cool,
but the more rats you add to the box,
the more fucked up behavior starts
manifesting itself.
There's starts.
A lot of them become neurotic.
They started like tweaking and some of
them like become duddy and they sit by
themselves and shake.
They.
They develop all this nutty sensory
overload ship because there's too many
rasters started attacking each other and
getting violent.
It gets bad man and that's what happens
when fucking people.
When I was in North Carolina last week,
man,
it was a couple of days ago,
it was like North Carolina.
You could smell it.
Man.
It was nice to.
Everybody was cool right out to.
Yeah,
you go to restaurants.
How you doing?
How can we help you out?
Or would you like something to drink?
Like everyone's like tying to move there
and hang out with cliff.
He be now,
right?
He lives in Raleigh.
That's even,
I would just need to play.
Well,
you know,
Raleigh,
I could fucking do stand up there.
I can always just turn up with Charlie
goodnight's,
you know,
that's a good club.
Easily takeover child.
Good nights during the week to show it
hurricanes.
No,
fuck.
That sucks.
Hard Dude.
One of the waitresses at the place we
ate,
we had this cool barbecue place and the
waitress said to us,
uh,
that uh,
hurricane came and uh,
picked up her neighbor's house and
dropped it.
Paul would them in it.
They were in their fucking house.
It picked,
it's not a mobile house.
A house picked her house up and fucking
fluid like 30 yards down the road into a
pond.
You know,
I totally forgot about storms.
I just hate being around tornadoes and
storms.
Fucking whether living in Ohio has raped
me of like,
I'm scared of fucking lightning now
because I've just been through so much
fucking crap.
I think the move is a smaller town in
California.
I think San Diego or Santa Barbara
Diego's not a bad,
but San Diego is so close to Barbara
that's funded buyers now.
That's not a bad one.
Santa Barbara is a good call.
God,
that's a good call because it's still
like they have good restaurants,
diversity of babies.
So yeah man,
there's a university there so that
people could,
uh,
that's a good jail.
I love that jail.
It's awesome.
Look up the um,
the,
there's a university up there,
a couple.
I think there's more than one,
right?
Yeah.
And then this line is good Jujitsu up.
There was no comedy club up there,
but you could do something around a
campfire at this point.
I'm really seriously thinking about
getting some regular gig somewhere.
Just have a campfire,
a campfire in a winery.
Tickets are $25 a year.
Just,
you know,
doing a Gig like in Vegas,
like every week.
The that's the to place.
You could do it every week because new
people come in every week,
you know,
there's always people coming in,
but vegas is just so bad,
so bad for you.
It's not good to stay there.
Vegas is like,
it's like smoking cigarettes.
It's like you can get away with it for a
long time.
Eventually it's gonna get
you know or,
or you could not do it and then you get
hit by a bus tomorrow and you're like,
oh,
I don't know.
Like I never say I should've moved to
Vegas,
but I think doing a Gig in Vegas,
even if I did it,
I'd still wouldn't live there.
I would fly in and you know,
on the weekends I wouldn't be able to do
like one of those five nights a week
gigs.
I can't do five nights a week.
I'll lose my marbles for sure.
Five nights a week to I'm not going to
be funny.
You know,
comedy,
a lot of it is a based on enthusiasm and
I think if I did every night I had to do
five nights a week.
I don't think I would be as
enthusiastic.
I like little days off sometimes on the
weekend off here and it gets the juices
all fired up and that's the best way to
try to create new material to.
You can't create new material if you're
always doing long headlines sets all the
time.
I think the better way to do it is to
just really sit down and try to break
out some new ideas then just go up and
try them on their own.
You know,
it's the,
I used to introduce them to bits,
but sometimes you know,
introduce them like in the middle of
bits.
And I still do that sometimes,
but I think maybe the best way to do is
just go on stage,
like some crappy open mic night or
something like that.
You know,
you gotta make sure there's some.
I think I'm going to do that at the
Improv.
I'm going to do a,
the ideas,
uh,
new shit show.
Do a show a real cheap so that the club
gets something like five bucks or
something like that.
And then just work on all new material,
you know,
not even have an opening act,
nothing.
Then I was just meeting,
go up like an hour and a half or
something like that.
You know,
I'm thinking about doing that.
I think that's,
that might be a good mood.
I want to try all sorts of different
stuff to come up with new material,
you know?
I mean,
you can only get in the isolation tank
so many times.
He only look online so many times
I'm going to canoe.
I'm misconstruing like crazy.
Do you ever get really stoned and go
canoeing?
It was the best man.
They were just going through nature and
this in this boat.
Once in a while it gets crazy right now
we're going to die and then you're back
to peace.
It is so fun.
I'm not until I put myself in that,
oh my God,
you're almost done.
Canoeing is like.
I mean,
it just gets a little rapping like
you're like this,
but it's not like people all pools and
stuff.
People died.
There was a reality show that they were
filming for.
Um,
I forget what you could stand in it.
It's like this,
like this team.
It's not like this girl was
white.
She was white water canal and uh,
it went under and she should have been
okay,
but she hit her head and her head
somehow or another got wedged between
two rocks and she got stuck so she went
out and got stuck under and they had to
go under
or out.
It's crazy.
Can you imagine the canoeing?
I did.
I've been going since I was a kid.
And it's like,
it's for babies.
It's so peaceful and fun in your life.
People like stop and Margo and a lake,
you know,
like Oh yeah,
like to.
I just don't like it.
Cool.
Yeah.
I just
downwards like letting the boat go into
rocks and shit.
I try to avoid those.
Oh No.
Left,
left,
left.
No,
you don't have any desire to put myself
in the situation.
Wow.
I'm trying not to have the fucking
canoed tip over
you.
Just,
you don't like the Hickey Water?
No,
no.
Another thing it would freak me out is
that's how
one that I'm vbs dot TV show about the
Arctic.
Remember there was at one dude,
I think his name was [inaudible] and he
lives in Alaska and northeast Alaska.
Their daughter fell off the boat when it
was.
She was two years old.
They were,
they were living up there in the
fucking,
the Yukon,
wherever the hell it is up there.
What is it called up there?
North Arctic,
whatever the fuck it is.
I mean these way in the Arctic Circle,
whatever.
He's waiting to fuck up their deep,
deep,
deep into Alaska and his,
uh,
they were on a river with a canoe and
the canoe tipped over and their daughter
was two years old and she drowned and
all they ever found was her little boot
and that,
that killed me.
That story killed me.
And every year they go to this site,
like near where where it happened and
they plant flowers because I wasn't
flowers like ribbons because there's no
flowers up there.
And it was sad as fuck by watching them
cry.
And they had two grown daughters,
like the edit to two daughters
afterwards,
but it's still crushed them thinking
about their two year old that drowned in
their canoe.
Fuck a canoe,
narrow,
not interested,
not interested in putting my life at
risk for some fucking natural river
ride.
Thrill.
Not Interesting.
No.
I mean I understand that this might be a
thrill,
but my logic will not let me get past a
risk to benefit ratio.
I look at it and I get angry with myself
for even thinking about trying.
It just seems like it's dumb.
Know.
Yeah,
so good luck on your boat.
Faggot.
What else?
Two thousand 12 tour with Stan.
Hope is well.
Last time Stan hope and I talked.
He wanted to do it and I want to do it.
I think that would be awesome.
Have an end of the world show and then
the real end of the world would be that
the world wouldn't end ever ever read
book.
Behold a pale horse.
Yeah.
I think it's not that you think it's a
great conspiracy book.
Death rock dance.
I thought it was a bad book.
I thought that guy sounds like he's
enough.
Sounds like either he's crazy or he's
like a disinflation guy and there are
people without a doubt who are paid to
say things that seem like nonsense and
say those nonsense things along with
things that do make sense and are true
and real and thereby the nonsense
discredits the real information.
So,
you know,
if someone says like,
did you know that,
you know,
uh,
the,
the government did this in 1970 and then
you can go,
oh really?
Where'd you read that?
And you go,
well,
I read it from William Cooper's book.
You know,
I'm not the guy that believes there's
alien bases on the moon that are
watching us and that there's information
that they have given us to.
Oh,
come on,
man,
that guy sounds like a balloon.
He sounds fucking crazy.
He's a guy that also said that the
driver is the one who killed Kennedy.
He believes that the driver,
the driver turned around and shot
Kennedy and then could clearly see it
and there's a or felt like he's nuts.
He says,
shit,
that's so nutty.
I have to believe there's one or two
options,
either he's completely out of his
fucking mind and people just believed
him
or he's a plant.
He's a guy that they hired to,
to distribute this information to make
things and theories appear ridiculous.
It's very possible that he's,
that there's definitely people that do,
that.
There's people that have admitted that
the government hires people to blog,
hires people to uh,
go online and post on message boards and
debate issues.
Anytime anything specific comes up,
they have guys that they'll send on that
issue if they believe that this is
causing descent and some sort of a meme
of consciousness if they can avoid,
you know,
they'll attack it.
They'll try to discredit things,
you know,
it says means pretty standard.
I mean,
they would have to do that.
They've got to realize how big the
Internet is
as you hold that fucking hard drive
noise.
My computer's about to die.
Flash player support safari.
Fuck you.
They want me to send in a report.
You know your shit.
So actually I get a recording flash
buyers guide.
Well,
it quit on safari browser.
It didn't quit on Firefox.
Safari can soccer.
Oh,
ficus.
Flash,
flash to html.
Five point.
Oh,
somebody.
They made it into two.
You could play quake two in your
browser.
60 frames per second.
Just going to a website.
This,
this guy's hilarious.
The government is.
I wonder if you tell them the truth.
Let me start shaking my keys.
Every time I talk to you shaking your
community that help my friend and have
to do that because they,
they,
their mind wanders.
So sigma keys.
I was just listening to what this guy
wrote.
The government is only out to protect
itself from the rest of us.
I wonder if he's being serious.
Some people really think like that.
We got my to do that because otherwise
people would overthrow the government.
The whole idea is,
you're not supposed to say this,
but the whole idea that everybody should
have a say in how the world works is
ridiculous.
It's just too many dummies out there and
there's no way to stop that.
You know,
we,
we have kind of bypassed nature and it's
strong.
It's not only the strong survive
anymore,
it's everybody survives.
You know,
it's like,
no matter what,
we try to keep you going,
you know,
he can be the dumbest motherfucker ever
and we try to keep it going.
That,
that didn't always used to be the case
and I think because it is the case,
you know,
it's just,
just way too many dummies.
The irregular democracy just wasn't
going to work.
I think that's one of the reasons why
the government is completely full of
shit and why there's just such a cash
grab at the top and why you know,
why they still push war and why they
still.
Because they know,
they know that there's no way.
There's no way this fucking system is
supposed to be working.
You can't.
You can't have a regular real democracy.
People are too dumb.
You know the Sarah Palin thing proves
all that and know,
look how many people are into that
check.
That's amazing.
You would think that in a society in
2010 that someone who literally doesn't
read at all,
like you find out about that and you'd
be like,
get that crazy bitch outta here.
Like she can't be president,
but no,
people love it.
They love her more than ever.
What?
I agree,
I've hit the wall like starting to go
across.
I do.
You need to take vitamins.
That's a lot of times,
you know,
but you can't just say that we're not
even going to hit the two hour mark.
These people are listening to us and
their board now.
Huh?
Should be,
are listening.
People download this shit on.
I approximately.
We're the longest podcast in those
history of the Internet.
You know that stuff is true.
No.
Go look and buddy must've had a longer
with her.
That's ridiculous.
However you being silly.
So probably just ain't never no pants on
guy talking about nine slash 11.
It's podcast is nine hours long.
Does it every day.
We will not be suppressed.
Lisa interview with Alex Jones on
something the other day.
CNN.
Yeah.
What was it like?
Somebody said it right that 98 percent
of the time.
Ninety nine percent.
Right?
Right.
Well that's a really.
I don't know.
I might have paraphrased and made it
much better.
I'm going to use that no doubt.
But that's,
I think that's really what it is at a
certain point in time.
You know,
you got to listen to some of that shit
that he says he's right about a lot of
shit.
He's just so crazy.
It's hard to take them seriously.
You know,
everybody's like,
is Alex Joseph Disinformation agent?
I hope not because I think he's my
friend.
If it turns out it's just a district
information age and he's been fucking
with me the whole time.
That's ridiculous.
She had definitely been friends with me
instead of the government.
You'd dummy.
That's the case.
I'm way more fun to hang out with them.
The government,
you know,
if you've got to make money off the
government,
he doesn't need it.
He's an entertaining you.
He's an entertaining speaker.
I enjoy listening to him talk.
He gets fucking crazy about shit and
some of his videos are pretty goddamn
jam up.
Some of his videos are pretty.
God damn good.
Have you ever watched nine slash 11?
The road to conspiracy or the.
The road to a fuck.
It was a called.
I've watched him conspiracies,
which should be called have watched it
to me,
but you know,
there's a point,
there comes to a point you can't believe
anybody because you weren't there and
you can believe this side is that.
So to me,
I just become,
you know,
what avoids each other.
I don't give a fuck.
What am I concerned?
Even
the nine slash 11 stuff.
It was the stuff in the World Trade
Organization.
It was a stuff on these people that were
paid to disrupt peaceful protests.
They would hire cops to go in and dress
up as a people with ski masks on and
start smashing cars and shit,
you know,
and he documents it all in and really
fucking exposes the shit out of it.
And apparently it's a common tactic and
that's why,
you know,
whenever there's a demonstration
anywhere that's ever anything important
ever with involving world leaders and
they're always the violence in these
demonstrations.
Even if the people that are into this
idea or completely nonviolent,
you know,
even if it's Buddhists,
against,
uh,
you know,
something that,
that's happening in China and they all
Buddhist show up and protest real
Buddhists still,
someone will be smashing windows and
some shit will happen.
Will they have to bring in cops.
And the reason why is because they do
that.
They do that to make a nonviolent
protest,
a violent one so they can break it up.
I mean,
that's real shit.
The government's been doing that
forever.
That is so fucking corrupt,
so wrong on so many levels.
And yet you never even hear about it.
And then they throw people in jail left
and right for not paying the taxes.
When was the last time anybody got
thrown in jail for being a provocateur?
You know,
what was the last time he got got thrown
in jail for being a,
you know,
a professional anarchist,
for being someone who gets hired to go
up and cause chaos and,
and create,
uh,
create drama so they can have an excuse.
That shit should be led.
That's like fucking treason.
That really is.
That's like,
that's like slavery,
like you're,
you are faking shit and fucking shit up
and people are going to get locked in a
cage because of you,
because of what you did.
You've taken away their freedom even
temporarily.
Some of them are actually going to go to
jail for long periods of time because
you're going to create trumped up
charges of violence on them because
there's some shit that you guys cost.
That's.
That's tyranny.
That really is treason.
That's,
that's a person who should not be
allowed to be an American.
You know you are.
You are corrupting everything.
That's great about what America is
supposed to stand for you fucking cunts.
Right?
He's done.
Done.
Folks.
I'm going to answer a couple more
questions because we can't end like
this.
Fucking low blood sugar faggot.
I'm going to get them a plum.
I probably am low blood sugar.
I know you're low blood sugar.
You got an issue,
so we need to get you some supplements.
Do you?
Well,
I have nothing anymore.
You don't understand.
I didn't even have pots and pans
anymore.
I reason I had a roommate move out the
hand.
Your roommate took everything.
Everything.
Was it all your stuff?
Well,
like most of the big stuff is mine,
but when you realize,
oh no,
pots and pans.
Oh no dish.
So.
Oh no toilet paper.
Oh No.
Got To start from scratch and you don't
even know what you're missing now.
You know?
It's crazy.
Wow.
Very crazy.
Yeah.
That's always a weird thing,
man.
When you live with somebody for three
years and then you break up and then
they move out and you're like,
wow,
now what?
Fucking out what gets strange.
You know,
if it gets really weird how you become
so comfortable with living with somebody
new,
with not only that,
you get so accustomed to having that
personal time we addict to each other.
That's why people get so terrified when
people want to break up.
Right.
You know,
people get terrified.
They're like,
I'm addicted to you in my life will be
hell if you leave,
you know?
And that's really what it's like
sometimes.
You know,
sometimes people obsess on relationships
for long periods of time,
but God so,
so much more often when the relationship
is over,
you feel so much better once it levels
out like what I want to,
I want to fucking go canoeing and then
maybe roller rollerskating or something
where you were involved in a situation
where,
I mean,
I don't know how much you want
to talk about it,
but you were involved in a situation
where you felt like you were the person
who wasn't very happy and you're a
pretty easy going kind of silly guy.
It's also,
there's a problem too and having um,
a relationship with someone sometimes
he's really struggling and you're not
like,
you know,
you don't have to get up at a specific
time every day.
That's,
that seems like a for crime with my
whole life now because now you,
you,
most people have nine to five jobs and
it's really hard to,
to think that like,
oh,
this person doesn't
five that you enjoy is not that bad.
You know,
those people are usually fairly fun,
right.
You know,
or at least fairly happy.
But in nine to five that you hate,
that's hard,
that's hard saucepan.
That's hard to us to solve.
It gets to a point where,
um,
you know,
like too much of a percentage of your
day is,
is pushed into the negative zone and you
start dragging that negativity.
It's not,
you can just shut it off at the end of
the day and all of a sudden be super
positive.
Like you're kind of beaten down by a
boring ass day.
At the end of the week you get this
paycheck and it's like $300 and you're
like,
what?
$300.
And they take the taxes out and that's
what you've got left.
You gave us your whole week and we give
you $300 and you don't like it,
you know,
and you're uncomfortable physically.
You know,
it's like there's so many issues that
people have to go through.
It's fucking hard,
man.
But I don't think there's any other
solution,
you know,
I mean,
this,
everyone can't really figure it out and
find some job that they truly love.
There's gonna be people that are in jobs
they don't like because if they're not,
there's,
I mean we need to keep this fucking
society rolling in,
you know,
and there's a lot of shit that you don't
want to do,
right?
There's a lot of shit that I don't want
to do.
It's going to have to get done and if we
want to have a society like this,
unless we develop robots.
I mean is that the future where robots
do all the jobs that suck and then the
only people that are left are,
what were the creators,
the people who create things like what,
what the fuck becomes a bit craftsman,
artists,
creatives,
doctors,
engineers,
scientists,
people that create new computers and fix
the stuff that we have.
Technicians.
And then what else?
Then you don't need burger king workers
anymore.
You know,
I mean this is going to get to a point
where that's going to be the case.
You know,
you,
you don't need anybody to do anything
that sucks.
What's the deal with the longest census
survey that they're making you fill out?
Make you fill it out?
Yeah.
It says it's the law or is it like like
not doing your taxes kind of law or know
man,
until they can count Mexicans.
They could suck my dick.
You don't know how many people are here.
You're not going to tell me that through
your little pieces of paper.
You got it all figured out.
That's nonsense.
There's so many Mexicans here that have
snuck across the border and until you
can count them,
why are we playing games while we're
pretending that you know?
Yeah,
so I can wipe my ass with the census.
Shit.
I just think it's silly.
You given me permission.
I'm not telling you what to do.
You're a grown ass man.
You gotta do what you want to do.
I keep on looking at it.
I'm like,
Oh,
why?
Why do I have to?
I don't feel like I need to do it and I
also,
I don't feel like I to participate in
anything
extracurricular.
You know?
I mean you gotta come up with a better
way to count people.
You know?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't want to be a part of it since
and I don't think it's helping things.
I think until you start concentrating on
why the fuck are we in Iraq and in
Afghanistan until we address that,
I'm not going to address how many people
there are.
Stop it
stupid.
Stop Embarrassing Yourself.
Get fucking government.
You're learning everything you've
cocksuckers.
Alright,
a couple more questions then we'll just
get the fuck out of here ladies and
gentlemen,
because this has been almost two hours
as of right now.
Um,
there's a lot of weird questions here.
You strange motherfuckers.
Impossible to try to keep up with the
feed on the uh,
the youth stream.
You bitches her very prolific but I'll
check out twitter real quick.
Do,
do,
how do we pick the questions?
Topics for Ustream?
Um,
we just started talking
unfortunately.
Just pick it a little bit better.
We'll just start talking.
I mean we've always got something that I
pretty much just came over here and we
did coffee.
We smoked a little.
Then we started the party.
Yeah,
he came over here.
I was eating lunch.
He got in the door,
I said,
he wants a coffee.
He said,
yeah,
we brewed some coffee,
fired up a bomb or a a pipe.
That's pretty much it and that's it.
That's it.
That was our,
that was our setup
and if we had like a real producer,
we can take the ship worldwide.
I'm going to do a weekly Sirius show.
They're just trying to figure out when's
the best time for me to do it and it'll
be like one day a week for six weeks.
I'm going to do it.
It'll be on probably on raw dog and if
it goes well and if they like it,
I'll consider doing it every week and
keep doing that.
I just want to do more shit like this.
My only thing I'm going to say to them
is I just want to be able to put it out
as a podcast as well.
And if that's possible then I will do it
for real money.
Yeah.
And well this is a real podcast too.
I mean,
people,
I get all these emails from people
selling me,
they listen to the subway and that they,
you know,
they listened while they're at work.
And thank you very much.
This is from a web cam show.
This is just the raw audio.
This is so we've done no engineering but
engineering,
I think that's important.
I think what's important is the things I
like most when I listened to like opie
and anthony or bubble loves bonds or
anything like that.
It's like when they're in the middle of
a conversation and it's an interesting
conversation and I enjoy the point of
views and the arguments and
disagreements and the revelations of
these guys have.
I like shows like that.
That's what I want to hear.
I don't really care if it's produced
well,
that's all nonsense to me.
I just want to,
I just want to listen to people,
be honest and I want to see if I think
the way they think or if I can learn
something from the way they think,
you know,
and uh,
I'm going to try to do that.
So when they do that and uh,
I'm right about to do a deal to a,
it's not been totally finalized but
almost real close where I'm going to
write a book.
So,
uh,
I'm in the middle of doing that too.
I'm gonna get that shit crack.
I've been writing for a while but now
it's like the deals I've actually
finalized and I have it.
It's a form,
so it's gonna be difficult and I'm going
to try to update my website with more,
like little quick videos and shit
because it'd be harder to just keep
writing things over and over and over
again.
Um,
so the next show I've got is,
uh,
this weekend I'm doing the Kevin Beans,
Kevin and beans,
uh,
April foolishness at the universal,
a universal amphitheatre or some shit.
So what it is,
did it last year was awesome.
Those guys are great.
They're awesome.
There's a lot of funny comics on,
but I believe the shit sold out song and
I'm headlining at.
So um,
which is always interesting.
People get tired and also there's a lot
of topics or to get covered off to bring
up a price change topics.
So,
um,
that's it for this week's podcast.
I'm.
Thank you very much.
All the people came to see me in New
York last week.
I had a fucking hell of a time.
Thank you very much.
I was those.
I was so happy.
I haven't been back to New York in two
years.
I switched it up,
went to Gotham this time.
It usually do qa caroline's,
but I did Gotham and Gotham was fucking
awesome.
I love that.
I had a great time there.
I love this.
I got a big ass stage.
The crowd was great.
It was.
The staff was great.
And then I did um,
a Amos says south end in South Carolina
and North Carolina Rather.
And had a great fucking time there in
Charlotte.
That was awesome too.
So thank you everybody that came out to
the in New York shows and thank you to
everybody came up to the Charlotte show.
And uh,
that's it.
This is a,
the annual.
We're going to do another one of these
probably more like Tuesday because I got
to go to Abu Dhabi next week,
fly a plane in the middle two all the
way across the world to a strange land
and for sure I'll have some interesting
things to say when I get back from that
big fights.
Big Ufc fights over there and so,
uh,
we'll see you guys Tuesday.
Thank you very much for everything.
Thanks for continuing to tune in and uh,
I love you bitches.
Thanks.
I did some gang signs.